hello everyone mainly starting in more
five minutes from now we have not
started the workshop yet we commence at
the scheduled time
we are waiting for others to join as
well
and thank you nadeem for your
introduction
also others who have joined the workshop
meanwhile we begin
it would be nice if you could please
introduce yourself in the chat box and
tell us about your background not your
research interests
okay
a very warm good morning good evening or
good afternoon to all of you present
here
i would like to welcome you all to the
three days extensive workshop on genomic
surveillance of sars hoof2 variants of
concerned reporting in this workshop we
will learn about the ways the sars scope
2pentamic has transformed our
appreciation of genomics and
bioinformatics
and understand how genomic data analysis
tools can help identify specific viral
strains we'll understand multiple
sequence alignment phylogenetic analysis
and the significance of mutations in the
context of viral protein structure and
function
we will further discuss the viral
genomes of copen19 genes proteins and
the virology of the disease
we will discuss how the data and the
various analysis tools can help in the
detection of viral genomes compare and
distinguish between viral strains
identify the impact of mutations on the
functionality of viral proteins and
discuss virology from the standpoint of
data
this month we have plentiful of
opportunities for all the computational
biology enthusiasts
where we host various work
the first one that commences today is
the genomic surveillance of sars42 the
second workshop will be on march 8th
that will be on ngs single cell data
analysis and single cell rna seq project
support the third one will be on machine
learning for omix data analysis
then on faculty development and cancer
mutations we will be discussing about
all these workshops and the symposium
that will be uh
that is scheduled for march 31st and
april 1st towards the end of today's
workshop
so now let's get started with the topic
for the day
before we get started i would like to
introduce myself and the company for
those who are joining us for the very
first time
my name is sunali khari and i'm the
community manager responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are a part of a bioinformatics community
that is managed by pine biotech
we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy-to-use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with a number
of organizations developing a training
program for research oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
omixlogic training has been completed by
over 15 000 participants from 162
countries and over 300 workshops and due
to this fast growth our team is working
with local and regional coordinators
that are helping refine local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
i am honored to introduce the founders
and the team members of the company
dr alfred tauber comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and one of his major
projects is the establishment of the
topper bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brotzky is the director of
the troubled bioinformatics research
center and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics
our platform is the result of hard work
by some of the people mentioned here on
the right
julia panoff is an expert
bioinformatician
abby tatevsky leads the development of
the t bioinfo platform
dr mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and he has been developing
collaborations with universities as a
mentor and project lead for omix logic
training and research fellowship
dr raghaven lakshmi narayanan is an
accomplished computational biologist
with an experience in large scale
analysis of multiomics data and data
science methods in precision oncology
and protein dna structural
bioinformatics
dr priya opal is a post doctorate from
indian institute of sciences bangalore
with the ticket of experience in
molecular biology bioinformatics and
stress physiology
the omixlogic training follows
a project-based learning approach
which uses research grade tools to
analyze data from top peer
peer review journals
the training has been completed by six
different uh in six different
specialization tracks which include
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
in today's workshop
we'll be discussing about genomic
surveillance data collection and
sequencing
this workshop is in collaboration with
prima's life sciences
prima's life sciences is engaged in
delivering a high performance unit in
genomics by establishing brands like
illumina
and a few other niche technologies in
the indian market
the session will be taken by dr abhishek
bhagila who is the product manager at
primas life sciences
the next session will be taken by dr
raghavendran he'll be discussing about
the trends behind the emergence of sas
so variance
and before that he
uh he'll shed some light on sequencing
data analysis viral genomes
so before we get started with today's
brainstorming workshop sessions
let's just quickly sign up on the
omixlogic learn portal
signing up on the portal will help you
get access to all the resources
which includes omixologic courses
including bioinformatics precision
medicine multi-ohmic sources which
includes genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics and epigenomics and data
science that includes bioinformatics
using r and python
signing up on the portal and being a
part of the workshop will also give you
the access to these courses along with
example projects
which are designed in six different
specialization tracks which you could
learn from and replicate for your
research work
throughout the workshop you will be
given directions to access the t bioinfo
platform for bioinformatics processing
and analyzing transcriptomic data or the
other types of multi-organic data that
we'll be exploring
the platform includes the demo pipelines
as well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
so before i pass on this session to dr
abhishek let's just quickly make sure
that we have all signed up on the portal
so that we have the access to all of the
resources that are required for the
workshop
just to make sure that you all are there
upon the portal i'll be sharing the link
in the chat box
if you have signed up on the portal
already
please let me know in the chat box by
sending in a yes or one
and if you have not yet signed up then
i'll just quickly demonstrate it to you
how you can do so
you need to click on the login button
once you click on the login button
you'll
see us sign in
option you can either create an account
for yourself by putting in your details
or simply sign up with any of your
google accounts or other social media
accounts
i'll be doing it so with my google
account
please let me know in the chat box if
you are going along and creating your
account or have already created one
thank you nadeem for your response
okay it's that easy to get your account
up on the portal
we can wait for 2-3 more minutes till
you sign up on the portal
and
for those who have signed up on the
portal successfully let me just give you
a quick demonstration of how can you
have a complete profile
it's very important for all the accounts
to have a complete profile which
includes having a profile picture your
name should be in title case please make
sure that your name is in title case
because that is the same format that
will reflect in your certificate for the
workshop
you can connect your social media
accounts and also add a brief bio about
yourself that could include your
educational background your research
interests what you aspire to become
and any other thing that you would like
to share
for any course work
that you will be taking up on the portal
you can see your progress here in the
profile tab itself and also look at the
points that you will achieve while
moving from a beginner level to an
expert level along with the course
progression
and those who have joined the workshop
as paid participants should be able to
find the link to join the slack channel
just to make sure that uh
the workshop participants have received
the slack channel invitation
please let me know in the chat box if
you have received one and join the slack
channel or as i share the link with you
okay so
i have got
just
eight nine responses in the chat box
saying that they have logged in
please let me know if you have logged in
and i've updated your profile
and you can take your time we'll give
you two to three more minutes for you to
sign up on the portal and have an
updated profile and meanwhile i like to
pass on this session to dr abhishek now
so you can share your screen
um thank you sonalika
now is it visible to nalikum
yes we can see our screen
also should we be waiting for some more
uh few more minutes
[Music]
i think you can start with the session
sir thank you so much
all right thank you sonalika a very good
morning good afternoon good evening to
uh all the participants for today's
workshop
and uh she uh solanika has already
mentioned about the topic i'm going to
talk about i'm going to speak on uh just
wanted to surprise you with the little
modification in the plan that you know i
would primarily be talking about sas go
to
genomic surveillance and it's reporting
but at the same time i would also take
this opportunity to actually to briefly
tell you about a few more important
application of next generation
sequencing infectious diseases
and uh so starting with the uh so
like we have multiple people joining
from diverse background and it's always
important that we should all be on the
same page while we start running
something so so let me just brush up
your uh sequencing knowledge especially
in gs knowledge that how important ngs
has been and how it has really affected
it has so it has created uh so much uh
uh uh so significant uh changes in
biology itself so when you talk about uh
a
human genome project which you all offer
aware that you know it took about 13
years
uh to finish the human genome project
and it took about three billion dollars
to to complete that
now that was done using the classical
sequencing methods
and over the period the sequencing has
evolved and now what we're talking about
next generation sequencing and next
generation sequencing
uh now with the with the advantage with
the advanced over the advent of
nexulation sequencing now it is possible
to have the entire genome sequenced in
about say one thousand dollar or maybe
fifteen hundred dollars and and that in
a few days of time so look at the look
at the kind of change we had
a paradigm change we had over the years
uh with respect to sequencing and this
is one of the important uh
breakthrough in in the history of
biology
now let me tell you how this uh briefly
tell you about how this next initial
sequencing works so when you suppose
when you have a chromosome and you are
supposed to
i did supposed to sequence the entire
chromosome
and you supposed to use the older
technology of say uh sanger sequencing
then how would you go about that we are
taking an example of only one chromosome
at a time so as for for an easy
understanding so what we do usually that
we have a chromosome we basically try to
fragment the dna into smaller fragments
and then try to clone them say suppose
we had this one chromosome then we that
we
basically fragmented it to ten thousand
dna fragments and all these dna
fragments are cloned in ten thousand
cloning vectors and these ten thousand
coding vectors are subjected to
conventional sanger sequencing that
would give us 10 000 dna sequences and
those sequences are aligned and then you
get a contain and you get a complete dna
sequence of one chromosome now
consider this is this is the daunting
task of cloning 10 000 odd fragments and
trying to sequence them uh maybe in a
manner you know which one which may take
a huge amount of time so you can see
this is one of the example i'm giving
here so you have to do this 10 000 clone
vectors you're supposed to sequence that
it might take about 34 weeks and more
than 4 lakh rupees to finish more than
about say 0.4 million dollar 0.4 million
rupees to or probably finish up this
entire sequencing so
now considering this this is a huge task
now how ngs has helped us to tackle this
problem that we can do the same thing
all these 10 000 dna fragments can be
sequenced within 10 hours of time 12
hours of duration and with very minimal
cost
so how it is being possible that what we
are doing we are doing massively
parallel sequencing so all those 10 000
fragments are basically sequenced in a
parallel uh fashion and of and the data
is generated simultaneously
and the data is acquired and is being
subjected to base calling and then we
get a dna sequence data in a very very
short period of time with a very limited
cost so this is this is the power of dna
and extension sequencing that we can
achieve uh
nowadays now just briefly uh brushing up
your knowledge about illumina sequencing
so uh what we have illumina sequencing
that the dna frag dna which is
fragmented we are basically try to
attach adopters to the ends of the dna
okay like if you remember if you know
about dna sequencing by single by sanger
method so in that situation what you
have you essentially have a dna fragment
and you know which primers to be used
for sequencing but that's not the case
when you talk about next generation
sequencing because you're trying to
generate data where you have no idea
about what sequence is going to be
so in that situation we basically try to
attach adapters to the dna fragments and
then try to attach this particular
adapter attached fragments to the uh to
us into a kind of a glass slide or you
can call it as a flow cell
in these flow cell the dna which are
attached they are amplified clonally
you know i'll just show you how does it
how does it work
see you uh so what we do in dna what we
do in pcr we try to amplify
one dna segment and try to make cog
million copies of that similarly all
these different fragments of dna are
attached to this uh flow cell and they
all are clearly amplified to generate
multiple uh fragments at the same time
so what you get finally that you get
multiple copies of the same dna fragment
and then these particular fragments are
sequenced
at the same time using a very uh uh kind
of a patented technology of uh
uh
sequencing by synthesis so what happens
that when you have a dnac dna a strand
uh which has to be with er the the copy
of this dna has to be
made so based on the uh based on the
based on the base what you have here
the modified fluorescently labeled
modified bases are joined by uh by this
particular method and as in when the
bases are being attached to the growing
chain of dna the fluorescence is
released and the and that is being
captured by the sequencer so if you
consider if you look at uh if you look
at this particular uh section so we have
multiple colonies of pcr products which
are amplified clonally they are being
sequenced and they are emitting lights
okay so if you talk about this
particular
cluster this is one cluster this cluster
once
it emits light or which which represents
g
another time it
emits light which represents c similarly
all these are being recorded and then
that is being converted to the dna
sequence and this is how this uh the
illumina sequencing works and uh
now coming back to the final uh
application of an exertion sequencing
and where exactly you apply that uh but
of of course we are aware of uh
saskatoon genomic surveillance is one of
the very important potential application
but when you talk about when you have
multiple genes to be sequenced when you
have whole genome to be sequenced
exhumed to be sequenced this is
particularly for cancer
for cancer precision medicine and so in
that situation you know we have to go
for an exhibition sequencing and when
you have very few uh samples for
sequencing very few target and one go
for sanger for sanger sequencing and
now coming to coming to infectious
diseases and particularly source co2 we
are going to talk about uh that in
detail now uh in general when you talk
about infectious diseases it is it is it
can be caused by bacterial viruses
enzyme or parasites and then they are
basically from you know this is this is
on the right hand side panel you would
see
this is the kind of infectious diseases
uh epidemics pandemics we had in the
past which has made history which has
changed lives
and
among all of them you know we're still
having kobe 19 which is going on now we
do have some which we do have cases
which are probably declining but you
never know when it again pops up with a
new variant so this is this is an
extensive list and i think this is key
this is key this is uh you know growing
uh every
other
year you know you get something
new now what is important about
infectious diseases is that you know
when you when we we need to understand
and how do we tickle them how do we
prevent them how do we make efficient
public policy
where we can have a proper genomics by
generic surveillance
so
before we basically get into uh
saskatchewan genomic surveillance let me
briefly talk let me briefly tell you
about the kind of methodologies or the
kind of approach we go for
uh
for next generation sequencing
applications in which it is
the
first and the foremost is identification
you know at times
look at there are few pathogens which
are hard to culture they are slow in
growth and so that becomes problematic
and there it becomes important to
identify the pathogen this is one of the
potential application another area is
pathogen genomics where you have where
one can try to identify the mutations
causing mutations for uh antimicrobial
resistance and what are the toxins and
villains genes are there in the
pathogen other arm would be to look at
the host response you know where you
would try to not only uh so it's a kind
of a combination combinatorial approach
where you try to identify the pathogen
try to see host response and then also
try to look at the epidemiology or the
surveillance so this becomes important
where everyone can go for outbreak
initiation strain identification and snp
typing and there we get a role of
genomic surveillance uh with respect to
this is epidemiology and prevention
now uh
there are two major approaches for of
ngs which is which has been used for for
for for for any applications in
infectious diseases one is targeted
amplicon sequencing another is whole
genome-based sequencing so whole
genome-based sequencing as the name
suggests that we are trying to sequence
the entire genome of given organism
being sas co2 or being orbiting ebola
so this basically it has a different set
of protocol where you generate a
sequence for the entire genome
while in case of targeted amplicon
sequencing we know the target which and
these are specific targets and these are
very smaller fragments of stretch of dna
which usually be which is which are
usually being targeted say for example
you are aware of the fact that you know
substance ribosomal rna gene has been
used classically for the bacterial
taxonomy and bacterial identification in
this schematics what i have shown is a
diagrammatic representation of sixteen
cyborgs in rna gene where different
fragments of the different sequence
regions are being used for bacterial
identification and in case of an
examination sequencing we basically go
for v3 and v4 region for a bacterial
identification so this is one of the
way of targeted uh amplitude targeted
sequencing or amplitude on sequence
targeted sequencing likewise for in case
of fungi we go for its region that is
internal transplant spacer region which
is between ssu and five point it is and
i put it is an lsu so basically these
are the targets which are used for
targeted amplicon-based sequencing these
are the two major approaches which are
being used for uh in case of infectious
diseases
and now coming to our very favorite
topic uh provide 19 corey 19 which has
changed the world and the way you will
live you know and i'm trying to just
portray a very kind of a very broad uh
um you know kind of uh
uh
picture where we have been seeing we
have seen that you know this pandemic
has really changed the world and where
you have a disease which is called
kubi19 and the virus which is called
sasco too
and then what has been interesting
that this virus has a very uh
unprecedented ability to evolve
now i am just trying to portray portray
here a kind of
diseases a kind of a kind of uh these
pandemic waves we had in india where we
had a huge number of cases because of
delta and then we had a huge number of
cases because of omicron
now how do we how are we being how how
are these all these uh virus this
particular
um you know patients are being diagnosed
by uh so that is being diagnosed by
kovic 19 rt pcr test or real thing or
rtpcr test and this is one of the tests
which is which has been used throughout
the world for the for the diagnosis for
the diagnosis of quote 19. now this is
this this is this is very very important
test because it tells you okay do you
whether the given person is positive for
kobe 19 or not but it won't tell you
about how the virus is evolving what are
the kind of variations uh it is hanging
so because most of us have heard and
probably have seen and most might have
got infected by any of these variant of
sas co2 and how these variants are being
described how these variants are being
identified that is being identified
through genomic surveillance
and so you know how do you so there so
suppose for example in a given country
if there are about a million tests being
done for
kuwait 19 rt pcr
but a fraction of that are being
subjected to genomic surveillance
because
we say for example in india we have
about say seven percent of the total
total samples are subjected to sas photo
genomic surveillance so as to get an
idea about what are the predominant
variants which is which is in
circulation in the country
so
now this becomes important
why genetic surveillance is important
because it can help us to trick the
transmission roots of infectious
diseases globally now we know that
saskatoon originated from china now we
know that omicron was first reported in
south africa we know the delta was so
much prevalent in india so all these
things are
being are being achieved through genomic
surveillance of saskatchewan
now other than that
it is also possible to determine how
quickly the virus is mutating
and what does the what are the
repercussions of this mutations what are
the uh
so basically these mutations
might lead to
a noble mutations which might affect uh
which makes some of the variants more
pathogenic and with the greater
transmissibility and it might also be it
might also make our vaccine less
effective and it might also evade our
test diagnosis you know you might have
heard that possibly the conventional
rtpcr test uh initially
were not able to diagnose a micron virus
or micron variant because of because
there's so much of mutation in spike
region that they there are there are
issues but then so these are very
important but then genomic surveillance
that means the whole genome sequencing
virus it gives you a very complete
picture that what is happening and in
order to do this whole genome sequencing
virus illumina has a test called
curvatic test which detects sas co2
virus in patients
and it enables virus genome analysis for
all these research purposes which are
mentioned above
now how does it work when you know that
we are so if you talk about the lower
panel this is about a conventional art
pcr based testing of for sasko two virus
and it just just tells you where a
patient is positive or negative
subscribe to
while in case of genomic surveillance uh
the steps involved will be a little more
you will have rna which is extracted
then you have rtpcr
amplificate pcr application library
preparation illumina sequencing and
sequence analysis
and
so now this is very important that in
sequence analysis what we essentially do
is to
identify the variants whether it is
alpha beta omicron or whatsoever and
then also to understand what are the
lineages you know you heard about few
lineages so we try to do phylogenetics
biodynamics and the variant
classification through sequence analysis
now lunar technology has been at the
forefront since from the beginning of
the uh uh pandemic where you know we
came up
we came up with this test of seek
genomic surveillance
in a very in a very very short period of
time
um i guess i can you have a question
okay you have a question
so
am i can i take this question
yes sir you can definitely take this
question at this moment
yeah
uh so yeah what is the question okay
all right no problem if you
if you want you can take those quick
that question at the end of the session
so uh
initially when you talk about it is it
was all about detection then it became
surveillance so today what we're talking
about is surveillance
and uh what what kind of solutions are
out there for doing genomic sequencing
of sas co2
one method one approach would be
shortened metagenomics
where total rna from the patient is
being taken and then subjected to uh sas
photo sequencing this is more of a kind
of more of a broad approach
and other approach would be enrichment
where usually what is being done that
the sas go to uh while uh
viral segments are enriched and then
that that is being sequenced and
detected
and the most common
approach would be amplicon based and
this is the kovidzik test which falls
under amplicon's
category and go with sick test it is
though it is amplicon based approach it
gives you a complete picture of the
entire genome of sas code too
okay
and now poetic test enables detection
and sequencing of sasko2 and we have a
couple of platforms sorry for the
spelling mistake so we have a couple of
platforms so we have so the this can be
done on very smaller benchtop uh
platforms like my sick minister kaiser
to a greater dual to the highly upgraded
and high throughput uh platform like
novaseq
and we have a lot of we have a battery
of primers which are being improved uh
regularly to cover most of the spike
regions of the uh
of the virus so that no we we do not
fail to identify and sequence any of the
emerging variant
now let me tell you how does it work so
when you have rna which is being which
was isolated
that rna is being converted to c dna and
then c dna is being split uh it's split
into two different sets of pcr pools
where we have covert sick primary pool
one crab coefficient
and this is basically to target 98
amplicons this one anti-templicons are
being distributed in these two tubes
separately so these 98 amplicons are
basically try to cover the entire region
of south code 2
and then we also have an element 11
amplicon targeting human messenger rna
as an internal control so with these
primary pool we try to amplify this
entire fragments of class go to and then
pull them and then have an internal
control
and then try to attach indexes and the
doctors and then try to sequence them or
using our our uh bench top to our high
throughput sequencing platforms and then
we get the we analyze the data whatever
is being generated
so how does it work you have a sample
collection sample preparation elaborate
preparation sequencing analysis and
report
and what is and so we'll understand what
how exactly it is being done
so further for the data analysis you
know whenever we do an examination
sequencing we basically get the uh
primary analysis done where you get the
information about cluster
and after that you we get an information
about base calling so all the bases are
being called and then we after this is
being done the primary analysis is over
then we go for secondary analysis and
for this we have a illumina dragon
kovitzig test analysis
and we also have covert lineage uh
lineage analysis app so in these what we
do we go for secondary analysis where we
do quality control of the sequence data
which is being generated and we detect
virus and we do we do all sorts of
analysis and make the report
and so what kind of analysis is being
done to get a more little of a kind of a
little more detailed view that
we do run we get the fast queue
generation files and from the data and
especially from say from this particular
um say a particular steps and then this
ask who is being detected suspect is
being detected and then we try to try to
align the data
with available database with available
sequences of various
uh various variants of
sas code 2 and then we go for variant
calling and we again generate
fast fast fast data and then try to see
what kind of variants are being
generated are being detected and then we
get the we get a complete picture using
multiple uh tools which are which are
there for uh for flash code to uh uh for
saskatoon lineage identification
and uh we also get a report about run
information how they run went we also
get the quality control information how
is the line and how the indexes how is
the quality control for that we get the
patient sample and control sample
results also sample id and everything
all the results we get here and we get
to know okay the do we get to know that
okay the patient is having suspo first
thing second we get to know
what variants are there what which
lineages are there so this is all done
through a very end-to-end pipeline uh in
illumina
now based on all this we have been
seeing multiple variants which are in
there and we have also seen the
emergence in the downfall of the
variants and that and to ours to to uh i
think i it it won't be surprising that
we'll be seeing a new kind of a variant
in the coming few months and kind we've
got a probably some hint throughout this
particular study which was recently
published and uh it shows that in new
york city see which a mysterious
chronovirus signal is being detected and
these particular sequences are heavily
mutated never been seen before and this
becomes a threat because you never know
how
how virulent how infectious this kind of
a variant would be
and it's still not clear whether this
has come directly from human or it has
probably passed on through a zoonotic uh
kind of a manner where it has probably
got incubated in certain animals
enable reservoirs and then it has come
to the circulation so so the point is
that there has there was always a need
to do genomic surveillance of sasko too
and today also i would say
that the the it is still very much
required to uh to
continue with the new excellence go to
so as to
keep tracking the kind of virus the way
virus is evolving
and i just want to hide a few things in
india what we have been uh associated
that in india we have indian sasco to
genomic consortium where we have
multiple labs about 20 labs which are
working under this particular broad
umbrella project where we're trying to
do uh
sas photogenic sequencing throughout our
country
and in most of the cases
we have been you know we the what most
of the sequencing has been done using
illumina quincy test
and uh
now uh whatever data is being generated
you know in our corona in in our
illumina end-to-end solution we have an
option that whatever data has been
generated that has to that that get
deposited in g said webs g said of a
portal which is a global initiative on
sharing even influencer database where
we have most of the data for kuwait uh
all the co variants of kovit um
of sasko to virus and we have now this
number has increased i'm sorry this is a
little updated number we have more than
1.3
um lack
of genome sequences submitted from india
and so this is one of the aspect which
is important now uh you will learn more
about uh the the kind of methodologies
and the approaches
for uh genome sequencing of source code
to in in the subsequent uh
lectures and discussions and uh so now
for now i would probably try i would
move on to uh two three more important
areas where ngs has played a very very
important role and it is worth
you know uh sharing this with all of you
so as to have a little broader
understanding about
uh about applicability of an exhibition
sequencing other than uh sas go to uh
vasco to generic surveillance
so another area which probably has been
focus area for for many of the
uh developing world developing countries
is tuberculosis and tuberculosis is a
disease which is caused by macrophaging
tuberculosis and most of the cases are
permanent tuberculosis and we do see
some cases of extrapolated tuberculosis
where other than lungs the few other
organs which are involved
and the the disease has
high burden throughout the world you
have more than 10 million incidents of
tuberculosis and 1.6 million death
globally a very very high death modality
associated with it and considering the
impact and
the importance of the disease who has
come up with a strategy called as the
ntb strategy to reduce the tv death by
95 percent by 2035 and this has uh this
is very very important initiative by wh
and
i want to highlight a few facts about my
own country where in india
we basically account for more than 25
percent of global tv incidences and we
have one of the highest burden of
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis and
extensively turbulent tuberculosis so
these are the tuberculosis microbiome
tuberculosis vector treatment
tuberculosis bacteria which are highly
resistant to multiple plants
and the exterior are the ones who are
resistant to even third line of
antibiotics
there are cases where there are a few
microbial trigger processes they cannot
be cured they are totally tolerant to
total or into all the possible drugs we
have
now this is the very creep
very very
alarming and very disturbing situation
we have
and what has been seen that you know
what is important is to diagno diagnose
the disease in a very early stage
and
mdr next year tv detection of these this
particular aspect uh this particular uh
um you know entity is also important
that we should be to identify whether
it's an mdr tv or xdr tv so because
unlimited until it is being done
we will
have a spread of resistant tuberculosis
and that will lead to failure of any
tuberculosis control program in the
world
now let me tell you how this works you
know when you talk about
you have multiple cares and multiple uh
healthcare facilities throughout the uh
you know developing world where you have
primary healthcare where you have a
facility of sputum sphere microscopy
where one can try to see whether the
bezel is there in this putin sample then
secondary healthcare have some facility
to do some rapid molecular testing
while you know the culturing is the gold
standard for maturative tuberculosis
diagnosis and because of the high
infrastructure cost at the specialized
uh safety level this is being done at a
tertiary care centers throughout the
tropical uh throughout the developing
world and so that is because that
becomes very important that you know
culture now another important
issue with this that mathematical
colossus it is fastidious it takes weeks
to grow
so it is very important that we should
have some rapid methodologies so that by
which we can diagnose this we can
identify and diagnose the mtb in an
early stage
now uh another important area i would
just take a few one a few more one or
two more slides about mtb
where i want to emphasize that it's not
about only having uh mdr tv next drtb as
a problem but
the tb has the tb bacteria
it also has evolved and it formed
various lineages
now there are multiple images of mtb and
the lineages they vary from the
they vary in their disease manifestation
their severity say for example
lineage 2 is more relevant with high
mortality it is higher mutation rate and
it is quite resistant very quickly so
that means this is the most dangerous
lineage then we have a lineage for which
is more likely to have consolidations in
the in the lung while infecting lineage
one is more likely to present bilateral
cavitation and lower rates of tb
transmission so at least it tells you
that okay if you have lineage one is a
predominantly image in your country
you probably have a little lower rates
of d transmission which is a good thing
to know about
and if you have a lineage too then it
becomes difficult it becomes difficult
time how do you really take out the
problem
and considering my own country in india
we have south india has
lineage one and the while north india we
have a lineage three so this lineage
knowledge is also very very important to
take to have a effective public health
policy and the uh preventive and the
content and policy further for this
practicum tuberculosis and
forget about north india south india we
india is divided into multiple states
when i look at the lineage distribution
of mtb i look at that that they are so
much they're so they're they're they're
the distribution is not uniform what we
could see that we have northern east we
have lineage too which is highly
pathogenic and we do see that is coming
here in mumbai so we need special
attention to to take out the problem
especially northeast so these all these
things so how do you determine the
leading edge so to determine the lineage
there are special set of techniques
special set of molecular techniques
which are being used for lineage
determination so this is and which are
very time consuming very cumbersome and
they are only restricted towards
pressure care centers
another challenge what we have the
non-typical psychobacterium we know that
classically tb is caused by macbeth and
tuberculosis but there are some micro
bacteria which are non-tuberculous like
mycobacterium avium uh mycobacterium for
twitter so they also cause tuberculosis
the problem is that they are resistant
towards all the they are resistant
towards multiple antimicrobial drugs so
it becomes very difficult to treat the
patients who are having co infection
uh
of
ndms
so this is one of the area which is
being neglected probably
many of the many of the uh
third many of this developing world
where we do see a lot of infection rate
of ndb
and then we have multiple novel
mutations in india maybe throughout the
world which are not being detected now
how do we
so what are the problems that we have a
problem of laboratory diagnosis of tb
and ntm then we need to know are they
resistant are they mtrxdrtv that means
are they resistant to first line or
second line drugs and then we also need
to know how are the lineages what are
the lineages and we need to know the
epidemiology and so what is being done
classifically that for laboratory
diagnosis
uh the culturally culturing has been
done using bacteric mgit then you know
do staining is being done and
so and for even for resistance even for
anti-microbial drug testing you know
once the microtubule takes time to grow
about four weeks or so that bacteria has
been subjected towards uh antimicrobial
drug testing and which against take
three to four weeks of time that means
about eight weeks of time to get to know
whether a person is infected with md or
hdr db and then for exfoliable typing uh
is being used to determine the lineages
now how all this can be done this all
can be done in a comprehensive manner
using next generation sequencing
and we can
answer all these questions using the
examination sequencing
so
there's a solution called duplex nyctd
it's a it's a cell it's a targeted based
panel which
basically target multiple drug resistant
mutations of first-line antibiotics
similar antibiotics new antibiotics so
basically targets multiple antibiotics
resistant mutations it also identifies
multiple species of microbacterium it
also it uses polygon typing that is used
for image identification so what we get
to know by doing this test we get to
know all the
resistant pattern so we're good to know
whether they are empty xdr and whether
and by doing species identification we
get to we come to know whether it is
microbiotic tuberculosis or mtm and also
this is most important point is that
this particular test can be applied
directly to the sputum sample so you
don't have to wait for the culture
of microbial tuberculosis for this
particular test so it has a quick
turnaround time of auditors and 384
samples can be run together
look at the scale to which it can be
operated you know and so this is the
this is the protocol where you have a
dna extraction library preparation
and this is end-to-end solution which is
being provided no one doesn't have to
worry about analyzing the data which is
being generated because there's a
difference web based
app which is available which finally
gives you a report about empty about
what is there you know so i'm just
trying to show you one of the report
where you have a patient name
and which platform is used for for
example illumina high seek and the
sample is positive for mtb it is
resistant towards isoniazid refractive
scene and so on and so on and so forth
the lineage is east
east asian beijing lineage two lineage
two these are the and these are the
pattern and these are the mutations you
see in the drug resistant genes and so
it gives you a comprehensive kind of a
solution using next generation
sequencing
now moving on to another important area
where i'm going to spend two slides only
which is you know we have been talking
about uh
sas culture which is a pandemic
everybody talks about
but this intimatable resistance is a
silent pendulum
it is one of the biggest threat to
global health and who has uh forecasted
that it will have a huge impact
economic impact and and very high
mortality by 2015
so much so that it might affect the gdps
of various nations and the huge cost of
uh cost of uh cost economic cost to to
to the tune of hundred hundred billion
dollars you know now let me tell you how
how we can check
this problem using examination
sequencing know what we have been
if you consider uh concentrate on this
particular scan uh uh diagram you would
see that you know what we are trying to
do we are trying to do antimicrobial
resistance surveillance we're trying to
isolate bacteria from human clinical
subjects where we are trying to see
what kind of mutations are there and
what can whether these bacteria are
resistant towards antibiotic agents or
not
so that is one way of assessing what
kind of a pattern is there but you know
all of us are aware of irrational use of
antibiotics especially poultry in meat
production and at times in environmental
uh where you have economics where you
have uh
horticulture so in discriminate use of
antibiotics what has been happening that
the bacteria which are there in these
animals they are trying they are
becoming resistant towards antibiotics
and we are trying to consume them and
when we consume them we end up having
resistant bacteria okay so similarly
when you have aquaculture where also you
have a lot of
antibiotics and then you have a lot of
hospital uh waste which is coming into
circulation there also you have
resistant organism coming into the uh
sewage or maybe coming into the water
bodies so it becomes very important that
we look at this entire picture
uh
as a complete uh comprehensive uh
picture where we do not only try to do a
amr surveillance with the in the human
subjects but also to do about to go
about poultry animals
and uh even even this even the water
bodies and other other areas also
so how in gs can be used that when you
have clinical samples
when you have strains which is isolated
so you have isolated bacteria and you're
suspecting it is having some kind of it
is can probably resistant towards
certain antibiotics so you know you can
probably through wholesome sequencing
you get to know a lot many information
out of this in the clinical samples uh
one thing one can get to know you know
you can directly use legal sample to
identify the pathogen and to identify
the uh
genes of interest for entomological
resistance what becomes very very
important is environmental samples where
you know in the environmental sample
when you try to grow bacteria out of it
with the thousands of bacteria and you
wouldn't know whether
whether we should really be doing a
physical drug testing for all those
bacteria so you know for encountering
samples it becomes very important to go
for next generation sequencing based
approach which which is metagenomic
based approach so our first to identify
antimatter resistant genes in the
effluent of human agriculture in
activities and we can assess the risk of
uh you know are good transfer from
environmental communication pathogen so
this is a tremendous application what we
have in case of amr surveillance
and lastly you know
i'm trying to
finish my discussion with the very
interesting topic of gut microbiome or
say gut is very but is probably a very
niche area but you can see microbiome
study through metagenomics so microbiome
being uh being in the gut being on the
skin
whatsoever uh
you know the places it has been linked
to various diseases like depression
immunity allergy neurological diseases
heart diseases obesity diabetes even
various uh
bowel diseases also
now one classical example i want to put
forward here is this about the
inflammatory bowel disease so using
nexulation sequencing metagenomic
approach shortening metabolic approach
what has been elicited that you have a
healthy microbiota when you have high
bacterial diversity
high fungal diversity and la less of
kodo will richness
and when you have this the entire
symbiosis is is is being maintained you
have immune tolerance you have a mucosal
homeostasis
but when the bacterial diversity goes
down when the fungal diversity goes down
and corroborates richness increases it
will list it will lead to inflammatory
response
mucosal mucosal ulceration and that will
lead to inflammatory bowel disease this
is kind of a phenomena which is greatly
implicated with respect to ibt and we
have many more such application many
more such area where microbiome is being
linked with various disease conditions
so with these i think i would like to uh
thank you all for for for a patient
listening and we have in this session
we've understood
the way in a very broad manner about
next generations how uh what is the
overview about ngs how it is how it is
being used for saskatoon surveillance
and in addition to that how it is being
used for tb diagnosis for mr
surveillance and for um as a good
microbiome study thank you so much
yes
um so uh i think uh if can anybody help
me out with the questions i can probably
uh
take those questions yeah thank you
for such great
session
so there's one question in the chat box
and uh nadeem is asking you is this
program used artificial intelligence
coding system
i'm asking about illumina
okay
okay yeah so uh
we we are at the moment so basically
when you talk about analysis there are
two options what we have one is uh
one is a base base hub
and another is a dragon server so this
is these are very high end
uh bioinformatics server or data
analysis server which is dragon and
uh which is currently being you know it
is which was developed specially to
analyze the data whatever whatever is
being generated you know so let me let
me just tell you about you know about ai
because ai you know you're trying to
train uh the competitor uh uh to look at
the data and and make some sense out of
it and so basically you're giving the
training data to the computer and trying
to you know program that okay whenever
you get another data you can make sense
out of it but in our case you know what
is the situation that we have we are
getting data which is dynamic
which is uh variable and so we have we
are basically using high end computing
high in bioinformatics to design those
pipelines for for for a very specific
kind of applications so as of now i
don't see i don't think that it is being
we are using ai for this
but uh maybe uh certainly we can uh if
something comes up we'll surely able to
let you know about that
yeah any more questions
uh
i hope nadeem your question is answered
and
i don't find any other question in the
chat box dr abhishek
so
if anybody is having any doubts or any
queries
uh please send the questions in the chat
box yeah so we have one more question
here
can we integrate two or more ngs data
and do the analysis example
are in a seek of breast cancer and rna
seek of prostate cancer so praji is
asking this question dr abhishek
uh prachi i think uh
um
so
you're trying to do data analysis you
know let me tell you one thing
there are two there are two aspects to
it one is to generate data and another
is to analyze the data now when you are
doing rna sect for breast cancer and for
prostate cancer
you can generate the data
together say you have samples which can
be pulled together in a novaseq and then
you generate data for these two
different disease conditions okay
but when it comes to sequence analysis
analysis is always done separately
because for each sample we have to know
what is there say when you because
breast cancer is totally different and
prostate cancer is totally different so
the analysis is always done separately
they they cannot they can they can
obviously follow the same similar kind
of pipeline but for each sample you know
the data analysis is done separately
uh so should i uh stop sharing
uh
in just a moment i hope practice your
question is answered
so i don't think so we have any more
questions uh
now
yeah if anybody has any specific query
if anybody wants to know further or
discuss something uh
something else also and so you are free
to reach me
at the email id which is mentioned here
and you can obtain this email id if you
are not able to note it down you can
obtain similarity from
sonalika
uh
so that should be okay yeah
all right so
thank you
yeah oh uh just a moment dr abhishek i'm
sorry so there's one more question
yeah uh so edmund is asking for a new
pathogen will a new sequencing pipeline
be required
uh
the the this is an interesting question
see uh for a new pathogen
you know um say for example sasko2 you
know it is it is a new pathogen okay so
when when we started doing sequencing
you know we had we had a fair idea that
okay it's it's a virus first of all and
what exactly you are looking for we are
looking for a genome sequence okay so
for
uh for assembly so you basically involve
a very streamlined uh analysis pipeline
that okay
the
that okay once the data once we do the
genome sequencing what kind of data
analysis is required okay you would need
a primary analysis second analysis would
be that to assemble the genome okay and
since it's a new pathogen we don't have
a reference genome as such but then
despite of not having that one can go
for assembly so so the pipelines are
quite clear that okay for any new
pathogen forget about sasko to say for
example you talk about any other say
organism where you say for example
a bacteria which is neo which is normal
when you try to identify when you try
which is normal and it has no genome
sequence available
we have a protocol on a set of a set of
binomial pipeline which and probably
most of us uh are aware of that that it
can be used for for even generating dino
genome sequences uh in a very confident
manner
okay
i hope edmund your question is answered
and uh
yeah we don't have any more questions uh
with us right now
so thank you dr abhishek for such a
great and insightful session
thank you thank you now i would like to
invite dr raghuvandran
for the second session of the
three days extensive workshop
so over to you dr raghavendran so as to
proceed with the second session thank
you
thank you very much persian thank you
very much dr abhishek for for such an
excellent session and following
following it up is going to be a very
difficult task for me
and you covered a lot and in a very
short time under a very crisp manner and
that sets the stage extremely uh very
nicely for the first for the further
next two sessions on the and also for
the next two days um which uh which we
are going to cover in this uh webinar
session series thank you very much dr
abhishek one more time and let me find
ways to share my screen
i hope my screen is visible
uh yes dr aguirre thank you thank you
for confirmation i also got that
all right
so i welcome you all to uh this session
for this program and we are going to
speak about uh
let's see if this is going to work yes
okay so we are going to speak on the
importance of the surveillance of novel
emerging variants and consequence of
large-scale uh next-gen sequencing
techniques that are um important that
are
crucial in getting the surveillance data
and also identifying
several different variants of concern as
we already know
due to the pandemic that we currently
have under hand
so
i will be speaking mainly about what
happened during the south
i mean what happened with the sequencing
efforts of saskatoon genome and also how
the pandemic continued to spread around
the world with
with its different uh variants and also
with the different strains so what are
the major concerns uh
now as um and in the past also what were
the major concerns ssr's cove two uh was
continuing to evolve under a unique set
of evolutionary pressures and also how
the ngs and
genomic analysis of these viruses are
continuing to be deposited on nbi and
also helping us track the past variance
and also emerging new variants of
concern and
effectively develop
new methods to combat its uh
changed efficiency or change the
virulence that we have
observed so far so we will start with an
introduction and and speak about how the
data analysis tools can be used to
detect uh viral genomes in exchange
sequencing and and to identify specific
vital strains and and also um
specific variants and hyper types from
next gen sequencing files in the form of
uh
in the in in fast queue format and also
in fasta format and several other uh
visualization tools that will help us do
this
analysis and also we will apply
comparative analysis to gain
valuable insights into
into the
variance and and its effect on the
proteins of interest and this effect on
the um
effect on this spread and its effect on
the interaction
of the viruses related to the or viruses
to the host and its um and its uh
ability to spread and its ability to uh
affect uh serious uh
uh implication effect ability to affect
um
uh the host in a very serious manner so
uh this prince and also we we will talk
about different principles of variant
calling which are
important and uh and it's it still um
continues to be important to monitor
variance in in the in this viral
pandemic so
so we we now have uh
we now have understood and we now have
uh some uh introduction in in different
variants uh of interest and different
variants of concerns and different veins
of high consequence so these three are
the classification screen
schemes that is defined by the um
[Music]
that is defined by the cdc and who so
first it becomes variance of interest
and depending upon how it uh how it
emerges and depending upon how it's uh
how it spreads through the other
countries and the pandemics and these
trains will then um
and then then promote itself to variance
of concern and then depending upon the
effect of this effect of this specific
new variance of concern and then um we
already have uh
observed and we already have known that
the delta variant of sar scope 2 is a
variant of high consequence while the
omicron is not
because it's just variance of concern
and
to help you with these different
analysis and to help you with these
the skills that is required to master
all these
analysis we have
developed and prepared expertly
expert training materials to make you
understand the logic behind this
analysis and we have compiled all the
necessary tools related to ngs data
analysis in the big data platform how
about bioinfo platform and in addition
to that we also have a specific set of
curated exemplar projects that will walk
you through the process in these
research projects from um related
publications using the publicly
available data that will give you a
sense of how to
start from the data and then go
step-by-step process of
uh gathering and piecing
important uh pieces of information to um
arrive at the very impactful biological
implications and we also have all these
um embedded in the interactive platform
that will help you master the necessary
skills and that is required for the
analysis of your data uh analysis of the
data of your interests or of the data
that you have collected um
in your um
yeah you have collected in your personal
research projects so you will be able to
communicate to us using uh
using slack environment as already
mentioned by sonalika and spurs and
this and also we have
several um
courses that is dedicated to ngs data
analysis in general and also to genomic
data analysis and also
specific to
infectious diseases and that also
involve
several projects and several uh courses
that specifically deals with sars cove
to viral sequences and analysis of these
hardscope two viral sequences so um
so if you are new to bioinformatics we
will start with uh something like an
introductory course like bytes and
molecules which is going to first
explain you or which is going to first
deta
give an overview of several several of
these um
several of these technical aspects and
several of these
bioinformatics um the reach of
bioinformatics in several
research areas and research fields and
then that will help you
understand or get a very brief overview
of the impact of bioinformatics in
in
biological and bio
[Music]
biomedical research in general um
so if you are more skilled and then we
can also
start introducing you to the coding
platforms that will be uh that will be
used and that will be very helpful in
developing your skills and progressing
your bioinformatics uh
expertise to the next level uh when you
are going to perform this analysis on
the
publicly available data or on the data
that you are interested in so uh these
will involve interactively interactive
platform as i have already mentioned
where you have
code blocks where you can practice and
perform your analysis and then verify
whether your
analysis or whether your
tasks are completed successfully or not
based on the example code blocks and the
test
try and test blocks that we have uh
developed for you so yeah
so as i mentioned we have
we have
created or we have
gathered exemplar projects example
projects which will walk you through the
process of
identifying or which will walk you
through the process of collecting the
data from publicly available data
publicly available repositories and
databases and also piecing uh important
um
analysis methods and important analysis
tools that are specific that will answer
you that will help you answer specific
questions that you have in hand
with the data that you have collected so
far and will help you to
generate impactful
reports and also help you to
relate to the biological consequences
related to the phenotypical
characteristics of the samples that we
have collected or that we have collected
for the analysis so this is one of the
example projects that
i
urge you to
urge you to check and urge you to
get an introduction to and
try this out try this out so in the
completion you'll get a certificate on
which
you can showcase
about your newly
developed skills and expertise that you
have gained so let's start that that
with that introduction to our platform
and how it will help you and develop
your skills and and gain a lot of
expertise in the related programs and
let's start with the introduction to
corona awareness and its effect on um
effect on the old population in the last
two
with the last two epidemics and the
current pandemic
so before 2002 it was thought that the
coronavirus causes only a mild infection
and a very limiting
inflammation in the respiratory tract in
the human being these viruses are
endemic like these coronary viruses
before 2002 were endemic to certain
geographic areas and caused something
around 15 to 30 percentage of impact
infections in the respiratory tract of
the patients every year and um
in specifically to the areas that they
are endemic or repetitive but the
outbreak of sars that happened during
2002 and 2003 was caused by the
a variety of such coronavirus that is
known as beta corona various and it was
identified at the time uh through
several analysis that this viruses was
first found in
bats and then it jumped or it spread to
humans from that so which
naturally means meant that this corona
virus is a zoonotic uh is of zoonotic
origin meaning it is found mostly in the
um in other species of animals and then
it jumped from it gained the um it
gained ability to infect humans from
its continued
variations and mutations that it came
from the other
species or other animals
so
that sars
epidemic was actually controlled in the
year around 2003 and 2004 and from that
time we haven't uh we haven't
encountered or there haven't been any
known cases reported anywhere in the
world but after that in 2012 a new uh
variety or new variant of this beta
virus beta corona virus
appeared in the middle east and hence it
was named as middle east respiratory
syndrome virus or mers coronavirus so
after these two epidemics that we which
helped us learn a lot of uh
insightful information regarding this
specific virus the pandemic of novel
coronavirus in outbreak in in 2020 that
started in china
was
actually monitored uh uh
uh actually live monitored through the
ngs data and through several high
throughput sequencing data that was
generated as the virus started to
spread its uh
effect all right throughout the world so
um
right now we are actually witnessing how
uh
different countries and several
different countries world health
organization and local health
authorities are
dealing with
or dealing with measures that are
basically are that are
that
[Music]
measures that are
derived from the analysis of these
big data uh um
big data
or mixed big omics data that was
repository that was generated using
nextgen sequencing technologies
and it was very helpful and it is very
helpful in understanding or very helpful
in devising several important measures
to prevent and to monitor the spread of
the virus and to handle the effect of
pandemic so um
so this
so uh common viruses as i already
mentioned these corona human coronary
viruses usually cause uh moderate uh to
uh mild to moderate upper respiratory uh
tract illness like common cold like
common flu cold and and um
some common core for something like that
so most people will
would have gotten infected with one of
one or two of these a variety of viruses
that goes from alpha to all the way to
gamma
in their lifetime so some of the most
common viruses are alpha coronavirus
beta corona virus and other human
coronary viruses and the virus that we
have currently is a variation or is a
strain of uh beta coronary virus so that
was named that is named human sarco ii
or covid 19
odin to their uh year of emergence 2019.
so to know more about this specific
virus sars scope 2 is a single standard
rna virus and it's
and its
reference genome is actually available
in the ncbi database for comparison and
other bioinformatics analysis purposes
on it is approximately 30 000
bases long and
the there are and the genes encode for
several proteins that will facilitate
the viral viral replication and other
functions and transmission and other
functions and
one of the special protein of interest
or one of the proteins of special
interest is a surface glycoprotein which
is a primer and it's it and it's in a
unique shape giving and the virus is
the name corona virus this uh
this surface glycoprotein
or spike protein will interact with the
host and is directly responsible for the
efficacy of the virus spread or
infection capabilities or the virulence
of this
viruses so established methods of
sequence analysis and established
methods of big data genomics analysis
are employed to study the variance that
is observed in the not only in this
specific virus specific protein of
interest also in the whole the genome of
the virus and its impact on several
different um
capabilities and replication abilities
in their
multiplication abilities of this virus
and specifically to those proteins which
interact with the host and
and thereby we can
find a way to find ways to
uh find ways to uh
develop
develop vaccines and other methods of
methods that will counter these
interactions with the host and stop its
spread so to to perform or to understand
the methods of analysis and how
these methods will help us in gaining
insightful information regarding this
this
this virus and also its uh
its phenotype and also its
characteristics we uh we know that
next-gen sequencing uh
technique is a very well established
method to perform and to understand high
quality surveillance on the virus and
its multiple variants in the current
pandemic almost all of the data that we
have regarding and this our scovid 19
19 virus our scope to virus in the
copenhagen diseases is generated using
mexican sequencing techniques and it it
helped us in
tracking the pandemic it helps us in
developing
effective techniques to
counter the spread and also
understand the phylogenomics and the
biology
phylo
dynamics of this viruses and also it
essentially helped us in develop
a dose of vaccine that is
that is currently in practice
all around the world so many sequencing
techniques as dr abhishek already had
touched this or gave you some
introduction in these
sequencing techniques we will just
shortly brush through this so many
sequencing techniques were introduced
over the years and the sequencing
platforms use a variety of read links
depending upon the sequencing techniques
that are
that are in hand and they can be um
divided into short read sequences and
long read sequences and the benefit of
one
over the other depends on the data and
depends on the question that we are
going to ask and
and the benefit of the short reads isn't
that they are short but they can be very
inexpensive and it can be generated in a
massively parallel manner with billions
and billions of
sequences can be uh
sequencing can be performed in a single
run so
when when the cost when there is a need
to keep the cost down and there is a
need to
when there is a need to perform
massively parallel uh sequencing uh at
hand then shortly sequences makes a
logical
mixer
the choice of short
sequencing technology makes most sense
long reads on the other hand can
actually help in resolving regions of
the genome that are generally
inaccessible to short reads due to due
to the nature of the sequences like
repeat sequences and the nature of the
sequences like inability of um
of several methods to uh
effectively
duplicate these and amplify these
sequences so
generally in the in the aspect of viral
genome sequencing long-range sequences
are not used
as such because shortly sequences are
actually
performing great job in um in giving us
giving us information regarding the
whole genome sequences of these viruses
but
but when you have a specific uh
pathogens that that yeah that needs
wrongly sequences then the advantage
advantages can be leveraged so when it
comes to generally a long reach
read sequencing
like oxford nanopore technologies and
its platform under under perfect
conditions will actually under perfect
conditions and also with high quality
dna sample can even produce reads of up
to 1 million bases meanwhile short read
sequences are
limited to somewhere between 100 to 350
base pairs in general so uh
yeah so we already saw that how
different uh methods can be employed in
understanding or different methods can
be employed in surveillance of the uh
viral
virus sequence or vital outbreak that we
currently have so one of the um most
used methods is collecting the specimen
directly from the um
[Music]
okay uh these dedicated sequences i i'm
going to attend a question these
dedicated sequences why use them or not
software methods no i mean we are going
to use the software methods to turn the
data from the sequences to actionable uh
outcome or impact so first we need to
convert these samples into uh
digital data that is that is with the
help of these sequencers so we collect
as as it is given in this slide so we
collect this specimen or we collect the
samples directly from the clinical
specimens and then we can uh
actually use
several biotechnological methods to
sequence all the dna and all the rna
present in that particular samples and
then we can filter out um
sequences that are specific to
virus reference
that are specific to the
virus that we are targeting for example
in this case uh scope
if we have a patient and who is infected
with sars that we suspect that we can
collect the sequence from his um
from his um
from his nasal cavity and and then
sequence all the dna and rna in the
samples and then align those reads to
the viral reference sequence and then we
can filter out the non-viral reads and
we don't want to
deal with their non-viral reads as of
now or we can
try to use or perform a denoble assembly
on the non-viral reads and then generate
the whole
viral
whole genome sequencing sequences of
those viruses and
study the different variants that does
present in one one specific um
individual um
we have in hand or we can actually go
for uh go for targeted sequencing like
we collect the c collect the specimen
from the
samples from the um
from the patient and then we target only
those uh sequences that are known to uh
uh
known to be uh in in current circulation
and then
we can amplify those sequences and then
seek amplify those
specific
sequences and then
perform
[Music]
genome sequence assembly and compare it
with the reference sequence another ah
this one so how are the non-viral reads
removed and what sort of issues i mean
you can
a normal mapping of the reads or first q
reads to the uh
to the specific reference sequence will
yield in two parts of our
data one are the reads that are mapped
on to the reference sequence and one are
the reads that could not be mapped to
the reference sequence so we can
actually specifically target those reads
that are not mapped to the reference
sequence that we have chosen and then
perform something like a de novo
assembly for further analysis if we are
interested in finding out other variants
that
of the viral or if you are interested in
finding our and if we suspect the
presence of other variants that is
present in these samples then we can go
for that or
any other further analysis that we can
also perform so we can also do something
like
this i mean ngs sequencing analysis is
also widely used in the metagenomics
area where
we can understand the population of
microbiome
in a healthy individual and also
in comparison to the individual who is
affected by
who is infected by uh by by some um by a
disease or by some altered condition and
then we can actually cultivate these
these microbiome populations from
healthy individuals and then help them
help the patient who is uh affecting or
who is
found to be infected or who is going to
be deficient in the population uh
variety of these microbiome sources
for for these methods and for these
for these approaches and the backbone of
these approaches are the high throughput
sequencing on action sequencing uh
technologies and methods so we will deal
we will discuss a little bit more about
how
how these samples are how the sequences
yes
it does have implication on the data it
depends on the question that we want to
ask for example
these unmapped reads can be can in
general be
for example um
reads or sequences from the host or the
patient that we are actually
sequencing are reads or sequences from
the
reads or sequences from other infection
or associated infection
that will jump on with the viral
infection that we currently have in hand
so
so yeah so they have implication on the
data it depends on the question that we
want to ask if we are actually uh
interested only in identifying the um
identifying specific strain of viruses
or specific strain of viral infection
that that this patient has acquired then
we will use or we will target only those
specific strain or if we are going to um
if we are interested in identifying the
possibility of presence of other strains
or other variants that that
might be responsible for an increased
rate of infection or increased
difference in the virulence effects or
difference in any other phenotypic
characteristics of these viruses then we
have to go or we have to try to
characterize all the um viral reads or
all the
reads that are um
that we that one collects from the
patient
that doesn't collect on the patient so
it actually depends upon the
question that you are trying to ask so
in general how we can turn these
biological sample into a digital data
like the sequence data so um this
technology this nixon sequencing
technology captures the dna sequences
and and generates and converts that into
digital data using several steps as as
it has been briefly touched upon by dr
rubistek also first the rna that was
extracted from the cells are converted
into complementary dna and then it is
sheared and placed in a flow cell and
inside the flosser these fragments are
then amplified uh using the bridge pcr
method or bridge piece of amplification
and then this flow cell is inserted into
the sequencer the machine uses uh um
basically the machine
uses image based analysis or image
analysis to capture each and every base
uh in these flow cell fragments and then
um
and then convert them into sequence of
letters
and these sequence of letters typically
read between or
vary between
somewhere around 100 to or even 300 350
base pass long and they are usually
there
they read
they they are usually um
[Music]
in a series of letters or series of
nucleotide bases that is a t g and c so
these are actually
assembled and these reads
are actually assembled from there next
gen sequencing
data there is digital data and this
digital data is the one that is used to
assemble these reads into whole genome
sequences and this is typically done
using a process uh called mapping and um
yeah
and and
this mapping process actually takes
these
sequences of these reads and then places
them on to the respective place in the
reference sequence for example here we
have the reference sequences
on the top
[Music]
represented as a single bar and then
these each and each each and every pixel
that you see here is actually
it's actually reads that are mapped on
to these reference sequences at their
respective position based on that based
on multiple sequence alignment uh
technique that will compare the sequence
letters to the those specific position
and then place them there so this this
visualization and this method this
mapping method actually uh helps us to
build or helps us to assemble these
reads into the whole genome sequence of
the sample that we have already and then
this
the coverage that we have a different
position actually characterizes the
characteristics of quality and then
helps us identify
different variants and different
mutations that are present in
in the sequences or present in the whole
genome sequence data that we have
assembled with the from our sample
sequence
in comparison to the reference sequence
that we have uh mapped our sequences to
our map tower reads two
so
oh he said the reads are not against
references or context
there are two methods to do that if we
have a reference sequence it is
preferred that you uh map these uh reads
onto the reference sequence and if we do
not have a reference sequence then we
can also go for
assembling
assembling the whole genome sequencing
using uh de novo assembly process that
is also
done so it depends on
the availability of the data and also
depends on some other
concerns also so
other techniques in not using the
reference genome sequencing and then to
generate uh different con different de
novo assembled
whole genome sequencing are discussed in
the
upcoming slides so
after these sequences are i mean after
these
these mapping is done so uh
we get a full sequence of the viral
genome that is for example that is most
abundant so um
these sequences or these maps that are
assembled into uh full genome
assembled onto the uh
placed or mapped onto the reference
genome and assembled into a full genome
will actually consider the consensus
sequence or
or the sequences that are
or the reads that are present in
majority of the
sequences and hence they are considered
consensus if there is a
if there is a if there is a disagreement
between
um
yeah if there is a disagreement between
the presence of particular nucleator
base in any specific position the
majority of
majority among those
bases will actually
contribute to the consensus sequence and
hence this method is is not actually
going to be very helpful in identifying
several strains or multiple strains of
viruses than we have that we have
currently so uh
when we are going to um
build or when we are going to build a
whole genome sequence from these uh from
these methods by mapping onto a
reference
sequence and we will be left with
or we will be left with a consensus
sequence and which
which we can use to
compare it to the reference sequences
and then
compare their variations with respect to
the reference sequences if we have uh
more than one strain in our in our data
then we might have to
deal with the data in a different way i
will i will come to uh that specific
question in in a couple of slides so
after this
this mapping is done and after this
assembly of genome sequence is done then
we can start looking at the
characteristics such as
such as variance or such as differences
in the
differences in different differences in
the different genes or different coding
sequences
um
sequences that can be associated with
the phenotype or that can be associated
with the function of the protein that
those genes encode for so let's first
actually talk about the sequences itself
and how these
how different formats of these sequences
will help us perform these mapping
processes so
we briefly talked about or we briefly
mentioned
how
how the ngs technology is going to help
us convert this biological sample into
digital data that is this sequence of
these reads and how these reads are
going to be mapped onto the reference
sequences so this is going to happen in
the format of um
sorry i think i overshot yes so uh after
which suitable software packages for
proteomics that is i think currently not
uh in the
um topic of discussion so we can
actually perform as i mentioned so after
completing the whole genome sequencing
and then we can actually identify as
variance of concern or we can actually
identify um
compare these
the whole genome sequence that we have
currently assembled compared to the
reference sequences and then identify
the differences or mutations um or the
variance that is that one sees or that
one observes in the sample currently so
uh these
reads are actually uh men actually
stored are actually provided to us in a
fastq file format which um which is a
text based flat file format that will
actually that stores
both this biological sequences or the
nucleotide sequences and it's a
corresponding quality scores
like for example in this one
sequence or one
sequence of a read it it usually starts
with a
it starts with a
header information that is indicated by
the
beginning or by the inclusion of
greater than symbol and this header
information will have
the read name or the length of the
length of the sequences or length of the
read and also other sample information
that one can use to
that one can use for further
organization purposes and then comes
after this uh then comes the sequences
that are called by the
sequences um
bases that are sequenced by the
sequencers themselves and um
and these sequences and their respective
quality scores are actually uh separated
by a line which starts with plus usually
sometimes this this specific separator
line that is that separates the
sequences and their corresponding
quality scores in the ascii format here
given here um are actually um
sometimes they're not given anything
other than the plus and sometimes and
they have the um
header information or modified header
information in them
as a redundant data and
the quality scores that we have
associated uh with each and every base
calls that is performed by the sequences
is given in ascii format and we can use
these or we actually
leverage this quality scores to
compare and to understand the
understand the confidence at which each
and every position is being sequenced
and when we have
when we have a variance of concern and
we immediately
relate that to the quality quality score
at that position and then and that will
uh help us and statistically or help us
evaluate the statistical significance of
that variant that we are observing in
that particular position
okay uh we will go through so once we
have this uh read sequences
[Music]
one okay suppose we have fascia files
from different patients how can we
identify samples belonging to specific
patients this is done by you can
actually identify or you can actually um
add specific bar codes to these
different patients in the sample
preparation process that will help you
identify or that will help you segregate
and organize
these fascia files from different
patients please yeah please um
check
those
methods how you can do that and there
are several established methods to do
this through this kind of organization
and barcoding also
so
once these reads are then mapped onto
the sequence and uh gen and and then the
whole genome sequence of of the sample
or of the virus is being generated then
we have
the genome sequence in fasta sequence or
fasta format a fasta format is also
another text based format and that
that helps us store the genomic sequence
of whole genome sequence
in general this can also be used to
store um
protein sequences also but in this cons
context we are
concerned uh with storing the whole
genome sequence of the viruses or whole
genome sequence that we have currently
assembled so this this is a simple
text based uh
file format which has a first line uh
first header line that is identified by
this beginning greater than symbol as it
is given here and the header usually
contains um
very important identification
information like the
accession id of the sequence
or of the accession id of the sequence
that
when it is submitted to the ncbi
database and it also contains the
species and
strain information of the sample that
that is um that is currently sequenced
and given in uh
in in as such and we can also include
the technique which is used to generate
this sequence or we can also include the
sample data geographical conditions
etcetera etcetera in the first header
line that will help us
know more about the genome sequence and
then comes the
sequences of the genome in the um
in its respective position
so
ah
so this is a process or this is
a very short overview of the process in
which
how the
alignment of reads are actually help
are actually performed so
these reads are aligned to this specific
position based on their multiple
sequence alignment and then this will
help us
for example characterize these uh this
specific stretch of sequence is based on
um based on this presence of presence or
absence of mutations in these rays so ah
these reads will actually cover uh
the frequency at which uh each and every
position is being covered by the
different reads will actually
characterize that the coverage of that
particular position which will help us
um
gain lot of uh
insights regarding or related to uh
statistical analysis or statistical uh
uh statistical or to validate the
variance statistically
so and then let's move forward and these
alignment files that we that i showed
you here and which can be visualized in
this
format as yeah
like this which can be visualized like
this and this visualization will be
extremely helpful in understanding or in
characterizing
variance when they are present in
regions like regions of high coverage or
regions of very low coverage ah like
here where we do not have any
reads correspond orbit we have a very
low
very
small number of few number of fewer
reads
mapping on to this specific position of
the reference genome and we can
use this coverage information to
validate the
variance that we are observing or that
we have
that we are identifying in our
characteristic in our characterization
and this is performed using
some of the tools like
igb or eugene or jbrowser that will help
us visualize these
sequence alignment mapping files in
sam or fam or bam file format and we can
also leverage the tbio info platform
to analyze such raw data and for which
an assortment of different tools
are used and these
two
these analysis will include alignment of
the reads to the alignment of the reads
and and
[Music]
alignment of full whole genome sequence
uh whole whole genome sequences of full
length also and and to analyze the
relationship between the sequences and
to
interrogate or investigate the
evolutionary divergence of these
sequences and to
measurement
of
gene expression in terms of
transcriptomics data and also to
understand the relationship between the
sequences and the structures as well as
understanding or characterizing somatic
and germline variant
calling methods in terms of human
genome sequencing or targeted genome
sequencing efforts so to perform such an
analysis we and the talbot bioinfo
platform is a uh is an example of a big
data by it for platform that can be
leveraged to perform all of these
analysis and many other analysis using
um using a user-friendly interface or
using an intuitively
helpful user-friendly
interface and this
database or this
platform will also provide you
a browser based visualization tool uh
which can help you visualize these
massively heavy uh bam files and sam
files without the necessity to download
these files and
perform these
visualization locally in your computer
so uh
all the functionalities and all the uh
necessary tools to uh understand and to
characterize the variance uh
or visualize the
reads that are mapped onto the
whole genome sequence can be
done or can be performed um using the
using the platform uh platforms
visualization tool
itself so
yeah
so uh
as i had actually mentioned uh
we can actually perform two types of
sequence alignment uh to gain uh
important or insightful information
regarding the
sequences or whole genome sequences are
regarding the
samples and viral sequences that we have
at our hand so when you have uh fastq
files from the sample that you wish to
align or wish to
align each read to the um to its best
position in the genome then you can
and then you can perform multiple
sequence alignment uh with respect to
the reference genome or when you have
whole genome sequences
i mean there are the whole the quality
of the reads is these are given in ascii
format azara and there are
algorithms like
fast qc and other algorithm methods that
will convert these qualities course into
readable scores and that you can
usually
analyze and usually
use yeah usually
relate to so we don't
perform these conversion and we have
tools that does the necessary job for
you in the analysis and right throughout
your analysis pipeline and right
throughout your analysis method these
quality of these reads will come all
along with you so even right from the
mapping phase and right
till the end of the variance or
identification of significant variance
you will be
taking or you will be
leveraging this quality scores that that
that is associated in that particular
particular position so when you have
fastq files as we have been discussing
so far
they can be aligned
to a
to the reference genome at that at their
specific position and there um and the
presence of their
variance for example here here here can
be um
visualize and then can be um
characterized based on there based on
the uh yeah using the visualization too
and also um you can also use some other
downstream analysis to do this job for
you and to generate a table like or to
generate a list like
output
with us with the list of variants of
concern or with the rest of variants
that are called
from the analysis of these
aligned
map file so when we have
when we have
multiple um
whole genome sequences that we have
acquired or that we have uh
downloaded or that we are that we are
[Music]
that we are
analyzing or that we have uh obtained
from the publicly available repositories
like for example when i'm trying to
understand for in this example in this
slide when i'm trying to understand the
relationship between the sars virus and
the
sars
viral sequences and the source code 2
viral sequences then i can actually
download
a set of
whole genome sequences including the
reference sequences from multiple
different geographic locations for sars
virus and also for the source virus
causing sars disease and uh and sars
scope 2
infection and then i can perform a
multiple sequence alignment among
themselves and then
and then
use those multiple sequence alignment to
perform pyrogenetic reconstruction to
understand the evolutionary divergence
of these sars and stars to go to
viral sequences in that case then you
are actually
generating a consensus sequences of
these multiple sequence alignment of
and then comparing that um comparing the
variance of each and every um each and
every sequences of these
samples with respect to the consensus
sequences to identify um
significant mutations and significant
variations on their specific
position or specific alignment position
or specific uh
sequencing position so
so in order to understand how these is
used in order to understand how this can
be related to the
relative the variations and how
different variations can help us
understand the biological significance
of these
mutations and variations that we have
been talking about
in terms of digital data analysis then
we
we should understand how we should
understand the
basics of genomics and basics of dna
code in specific
just a second my powerpoint is not
responding
yeah
can you see okay yeah now i got it yeah
so we have to understand what is dna
code and what are the different types of
variation that these dna sequences can
can have and how they can
impact the very impact the
biological
samples are biological um
function of the
viruses for example in this case or for
the
system in particular so we all know what
constitutes a dna code and how they are
arranged in the nucleus based on their
unique base pairing that involves it or
that associates a to t
and as g to c and they are arranged in a
sugar phosphate
backbone
in the dna in a double standard uh
helical
structure formula so there are different
types of dna variation and they can
actually
encode two difference in the amino acid
sequences that these
genes will
genes will code to or they can also
prematurely stop there
stop the um
protein
stop the protein
synthesis or translation processes uh
based on the nature of their variation
which we are going to dis which we are
going to discuss um a little bit in
detail so these variations are called
mutations and some of the mutations are
harmful when they for example change the
function of the protein by actually
changing very
specific and important
amino acid sequences in the protein are
when they prematurely stop the protein
synthesis or protein building um
processes
yeah
so
there are i mean genetic variations and
there are a specific mutation and one
must not
confuse and one must start
take or one must not relate both of
these in the same
in the same scale for example when we
have uh yeah when we have a system in
its natural form and that will be
a reference system and this does not
have any uh mutation for uh that is um
as it is representing most of the uh
population uh that we are studying of
interest but
when we have
uh
when we have for example uh a simple
variation in the genetic information of
this specific sample and that variation
is not uh actually harmful and that
variation may actually cause some
phenotypical changes in the samples that
we have or in the system that we have
then it is not a mutation it's a simple
genetic variation that one encounters
all the time in the biological
perspective or in evolutionary
perspective and
there are also some drastic
changes of drastic
presence of these variations or effects
of this variation that
that are rare and that might not
have any harmful effects of these
effects in the system that we have
currently under study and they can be
termed as a neutral mutation because
because
they are not harmful but
they actually induce
new functionalities or modified
phylogenetic characteristics of the
system that we have currently under
study for example this this specific
system has actually
gained
two new wings and also changed the color
so these they can be termed as mutations
but they are not harmful as they are not
affecting or they might not affect the
functionality of the system that we have
in our hand but on the other hand we
have
some rare variation of rare mutation
that can result in extremely unpleasant
or undesirable effects and it can result
in functional um
or it can impact or impair the system's
ability to function properly or function
in a normal manner compared to the other
compared to the reference are in its
natural form so these undesirable
effects are the causes of pathogenic
mutations which can
cause disease or which can
which can
result in improper function of the
system that we have so
so to understand the mutations we have
different types of
point mutations point mutations are
those which which are in which um a
single amino acid sorry a single
nucleotide at that specific point or
specific position is altered and that
operation can happen uh by a
substitution which can cause
several consequences to the dna code but
but
these several consequences
are due to
due to a minimal change or due to single
nucleotide change at that specific
position so this point mutations can
also be insertion where it also changes
the number of dna bases
in that specific gene by adding one or
one specific
nucleotide at that
at that point so
this may result in a protein
that is made by the gene that might not
function properly
so a consequence or consequently
a deletion changes uh deletion mutation
changes the number of dna bases by
removing one or small pieces of dna
since we are dealing with point mutation
so here
we are actually defining deletion
mutation as a removal of one specific
base
at this at that particular position and
this might also
result in protein that might not
function properly as it changes the dna
sequence uh of the gene um
with respect to the protein that it is
uh
actually encoding to so uh there are
also other types of uh
mutations that are not uh that does not
deal with the
specific position of interest or
specific position so insertion of
insertion of dna basis or large number
of dna bases that will also changes or
that will also alter the
dna sequence or genetic sequence of the
gene and a deletion of not one but a few
bases or base pairs uh within a gene or
within um
or within large proportions of the
genome will also
result in severely
non-functional or altered function a
function of functional protein so these
can actually remove sometimes deletion
can actually remove entire gene or
several neighboring genes so this may
this may not only alter function of that
one protein but also
several proteins of interest in that
several proteins
that these genes encode two so uh
duplication might also occur as a as a
as a result of mutation or
sir
as a consequence of uh variations on the
uh duplication
um actually deals or consists with a
piece of dna that is abnormally copied
more times or one or more times in this
specific position and this
this will also changes the way uh a
protein is being produced and uh and
will change the um
change the systems
phenotypical characteristics so a single
nucleotide uh mutations can have several
effects and several
they can be characterized uh
into a missense mutation where a change
in one dna base pair may result in a
substitution of one amino acid that
these actually that these gene actually
codes for um
that these actually uh this gene uh
actually encodes for that protein and um
the missense mutation will
change the uh uh or will change result
in a protein sequence with a
um
with a change in that specific position
or a change in amino acid residue in
that specific position depending upon
where that position is or depending upon
where that mutation occurs in the
protein that this gene encodes for that
mutation can be
can be harmful or can greatly impact or
alter the proteins function so sometimes
these mutation can be
nonsense mutations where a change in
single nucleotide base can actually
abruptly stop the protein uh translation
or properly stop the translation process
and then this could actually this will
result in a shortened protein and that
may not function properly at all or may
actually acquire some some other
abnormal function that is going to
severely impact the biological system or
the cell that we have in the um
under study so a deletion at that
specific uh deletion or the insertion of
a nucleotide at that at one specific
position may result in frame shift
mutation so uh
or loss of one or several dna bases may
change the genes reading frame entirely
and this also will result in a protein
that is usually non-functional because
because of the result and it may also uh
be completely
yeah it may also
gain some novel
function that is not going to be
beneficial to the system that we have
currently under study so to summarize
the genomic variation so they can be of
several types and
when analyzing the genomic data we are
looking to characterize the changes in
the dna code and associate them with the
phenotype
in specific so in terms of uh
geno genomic variation of
genomic variation in the context of
human species then we will have um
a single nucleotide variance or s and v
where a single nucleotide change may or
may not be present in the population so
basically this means any change that we
observe in our sample sequence with
respect to a reference sequence
or with respect to the reference genome
found
above the level of uh or technical error
or with uh with certain statistical uh
significance and they are they're all
characterized as single nucleotide
variance so in the context of viral
genome sequences or this is the variant
or this is the variance of
this is a different variance that we are
going to be
dealing with and our identification of
our
steps in characterizing these
viral sequences or these viral strains
will based on
based on
relating or based on
based on identifying the functional
implications of these specific variation
that we are characterizing at this at
that particular position in the samples
that we have
currently or in the viral sequence that
we have currently for example in the
human context
something we all
have been exposed to
is single a nucleotide polymorphism or
snp so um an snv or single nucleated
variant will be called or will be
considered as a single nucleotide
polymorphism when
when we usually observe that specific
variant
in approximately one percentage of the
population um that that we have
currently a study and that will
characterize as snp and we have several
databases to
cross check
our identified snps or when we
perform a mass scale of whole genomic
sequencing effort and
in order to characterize
the smps of those specific races then we
can actually understand or we can
actually characterize the presence and
absence of those smps in the um annotate
those snps with the known smps in the
database and uh i am maybe uh try to um
identify some of the smps that are
unique to the race that we are
sequencing so far so um this is only uh
uh in terms of um
mammalian or in terms of
human genome sequencing
context and we can also have a copy
number variation as as i have as we have
already
briefly uh touched upon where the g
encoded is actually
duplicated or
present in number of different copies or
number of multiple copies and that will
actually um
affect or that will result in multiple
that will result in
in the level or in the amount of this
gene that that is going to be
translated into
and and
all of these characteristics of these
variants that we are characterizing or
that we are observing when we are
performing maxine sequencing analysis or
downstream analysis of negation
sequencing data are actually
commonly referred to as the genotype of
the sample so our genotype of the viral
sample that we are currently discussing
will actually stop at the variant level
or variance level because yeah
and then
and uh these variants and identifying
the significance of these variants and
relating that to the pathogenicity and
relating that to the spread ability and
relating the two other important
phenotypical characteristic of the virus
will
will define these variants to be uh of
one of the several classes that we have
already uh discussed like variance of
concern or variance of uh
variance of concern etc so
so these
in in the vital consequence these
variants
in the viral genome context will
identify different strains as we have
as we have
different strains that are described by
their
signature mutations or set of mutations
or variants that are unique and that are
uniquely represented in that specific
strain or that specific variance and are
characteristic to specific strain these
mutations may or may not uh
impact
their biological or
characteristics of those strains but
they um they are specific and they
define those different strains so uh
let's say we do due to the um
replication of these viral sequences in
in our
during the
infection process and we have several
different strains that we identify and
these strains can be
defined by the set of
variations and they are usually defined
by the set of variations and variance
and that are observed in those specific
strains of interest or strains of
extremely
interesting concern so
you can actually do or identify these s
and ps or single nucleotide
polymorphisms uh or as variants uh by
performing whole genome sequencing
efforts and then um and mapping uh
processes and these mapping can be
visualized here and these
these
[Music]
positions where it is
marked
colored differently identifies the
variance for example in this specific
position
where
the reference is uh a
here and the reference a is actually uh
represented zero percentage of the time
uh in the in our sample data or in our
sample first q files and um a variant
that that reads g at this specific
position is actually um
represented is actually sequenced 100
percentage of the time in our sample
data so this uh yeah this can actually
help us identify
different variants
the specific position and we can
visualize that and the height of the bar
excuse me height of the bar will relate
to the
coverage at the specific position so we
can be confident of these
variants to be above the technical error
limit
[Music]
and
yeah
so this is how different variance
variants can be identified for example
um
i think the alignment is not
perfect this has to come here in
specific for example this
in this reference sequences and
reference sequence and this specific
position we have a t at this position
and we have um corresponding
nucleotide a
that is sequence in our sample so our
samples actually mentioned uh in this
this position of
in this position one two one three uh
there's a substitution mutation that
changes uh the nucleotide uh t to a in
that specific position we can also
identify
not one two one three but there is
another
possible substitution in this specific
position for example one two five zero
where the c can be or c
could be um
substituted to a but we are not quite
sure because it is uh represented only
in uh one read or one pair of uh read
in this specific context and uh that
might not qualify as um
has statistically significant variant
and hence that might be ah that might be
deemed as technical error at also in
order to yeah here we are unsure about
whether this uh at this position uh one
two five zero whether this uh reads or
whether this um
uh
whether this is um
substituted
to uh a or no or not this is due to the
technical error of the sequencing i got
here when we have more reads populating
that particular
more reads uh increasing the coverage
that specific position then we are more
sure about that substitution and we have
we might have an insertion or deletion
at this at this uh position
where we do not find any uh
participating or we did not find any uh
representation uh of that specific uh um
specific uh
stretch of uh reference genome in our uh
sequence to sample so far so uh
yeah
we had a question related to uh
um
how different uh multiple viruses can be
identified and how they can be assembled
so this is how they can be done so um by
by performing uh haplotype
reconstruction using shora methods and
these are available in the toward
bioinfo platform we can actually map
these
to the reference genome and identify
how many different strains or how many
different uh how many uh
how these different proportions of
mutations are present in and the reads
that we have sequence so far when you
have um
when you have a sequenced
stretch off or when you have sequence
there um
sample with a
with high depth of coverage and high
coverage and then we can perform this
type of analysis where we can identify
how many uh identify the
percentage of
uh representation
of multiple different strains or molten
strains that characterize or multiple
different
variants and yeah strains that
that contain multiple different variant
in our
sample first q sequences so this is
usually done by identifying or
understanding
the
the assembled sequences and performing a
multiple sequence alignment and then
studying how different they are to the
consensus sequence and after after the
mapping
process is complete so um
so that will actually uh
yeah such such reconstruction uh of
whole genome sequences of the viral
strains and to
calculate how uh different strains will
um
how their percentage can be identified
from there from i mean how their
presentation um
percentage of
observations observed viral strains and
and how they can be related to the
representation in a sample population
can be uh very helpful
when we are actually
dealing or when we are actually uh
sequencing um
samples from a mixed population or
samples from for example um
waste water surveillance data that we
are going to uh talk about in a in a
short while so um
so um
for that kind of analysis these uh
uh
characterizing different strains and
characterizing the uh representation of
uh
presence representation of
multiple strains and its
abundance levels levels in the samples
will become extremely important in
understanding
the presence and absence of different
strains and there
and they really and their biological
significance also so um
and this will also uh be this is also
very uh crucial in identifying
strains that are prevalent in the
current pandemic scenario for example as
strains that we have uh yeah currently
uh in um
that that is currently infecting us all
over and then we can understand whether
uh omicron is a omicron is still the
leading strain that is currently
infecting everybody or we have uh
actually moved past or moved beyond the
constitution
and due to the emergence of new variants
also so i will stop here to
take some of the questions that you have
looks like we do not have any questions
after any question after uh quite for
some time
before moving on to the next
topic if you have question please
mention that in the chat window
okay um
the turbot bioinfo platform doesn't
specify the software tools performing
the stage of data analysis could it be
possible to highlight the software as
opposed to
selecting the pipeline to be used
now it actually mentions exactly the
name of the softwares or tools that are
specifying the stages of data analysis i
can actually walk you through the
process of
this okay let's do that that will be
very helpful in the context of
current question let me
find ways to share my screen again
okay can you see my screen
i think it should be up
now
in a short while it's still
working for me can you see my screen
yes yeah we can see that's perfect thank
you very much so this is i also got
confirmation so this is uh
yeah so when you go to
the server and then when you do
something like
when you do something like uh
genomics data analysis in in the variant
uh
uh analysis so we can actually um
perform variant calling pipeline or
using
we can actually use the
demo pipelines that we have built for
you you can use a demo pipelines that we
have built for you once you have
acquired a demo license which you will
get
when you sign up or when you um
register in the omixlogic platform short
while and then this demo
login will help you access all this demo
pipeline which will
give you um or which will
demonstrate your which will give you the
um
and ex give you the experience of
building up a pipeline for the analysis
that we have and understand the
different aspects of different uh
[Music]
analysis methods that we that that uh
corresponds to or that will uh that will
be used to analyze these demo pipeline
that we have uh saved for you so
let me show you what what i'm talking
about so when you drop down this
specific uh
option in mutation and variant analysis
then you can use the demo source code to
pipeline here since it's a demo project
the meaning of demo project uh uh the
demo project means we have actually
performed this analysis and then stored
the input and output files in the server
run so that you can run the pipeline and
get the feeling of how to build um this
pipeline so
you can see here
the processes are the the processes or
the steps of building pipeline are
actually um
separated according to the
different uh various
associated uh algorithms that are used
in that particular steps for example we
are currently
going to start this process uh start the
demo pipeline and for the analysis of
mutation variant and we can also we can
also perform visualization
analysis also so first we have to
perform something like
data preprocessing which is going to
clean and which is going to trim the
adapter sequences that is present in our
ngs reads and sequencing sequence reads
and then after trimming and after
accounting for the pcr
artifacts and we can perform mapping and
we inside mapping we have several
processes like after mapping we can um
we can visualize the mapping or we can
do uh post processes if you see here or
if you start by clicking in this okay
this might not work so since um
you're actually starting it so um
if you go let me go back and then
click here
so if you click
on these specific uh on all of these
algorithms that is going to tell you the
name of the algorithm that you are going
to use and
and in general the reference
that these algorithms are cited for and
a very short introduction to how these
algorithms
performs this analysis so this is true
for all of these like yeah this you can
you can do or you can perform for
example ah bow tie based analysis or
star based alignment and this is going
to give you
some basic introduction and read through
how this alignment has been or how this
mapping is being performed and
you can also do
free bias based variant calling so that
is going that is also going to tell how
freebase is being employed here and how
what freebase generally does so these
are the tools that you find and these
are the names of the tools that we
actually use to perform these alignments
so
it is not
that we are actually
it is not that the talbot bioinfo
platform doesn't specify the
software tools performing the data
analysis it is there so you just you
just have to click and find out what
they ask what they are
yes yes glory you can perform a whole
genome sequencing analysis
of any
size and yeah if it is too large or if
your sample size is too
big it will take little bit more time
for uh for this to complete but it can
actually perform so when you sign up for
the
for the
subscription then you will get all the
necessary information or you can contact
spurs to gain more information regarding
your specific question so let me go back
to um
the demo pipeline
you can access that by going to the
so when yeah in the demo source go to
visualization platform i'm going to do
the visualization but
yes
yeah so i start the process and then
this this will actually tell you uh that
we have actually
included the input files for you and
these are the input files that we have
currently and these are the output files
from this specific uh
yeah from this specific processes so
this start process actually processes
the input file list and then builds the
necessary files that is required for
your analysis so we have several fastq
files here and this is a pattern
sequencing so we have one and two fascia
files and we click ok
and then we get a hint or we get a
possible um
possibility of the next step that we can
perform so here since uh yeah here
we can perform after start since this is
a demo pipeline we have actually
performed this data pre-processing this
is a pre-processed and cleaned data so
we can straight away go for the mapping
process
so here you will get again the input
files and output files from these
mapping processes and you click ok
and then after this you can visualize
this
the mapped file
and this also will tell you what this
specific algorithm does
so over this course of this building
your pipeline you will find these
specific or these uh these tau bird
bioinfo icon
on some of the algorithms or some of the
blocks that that is present in the um
pipeline or in the analysis or the
algorithm set so these means that these
are proprietary algorithms that is
developed by the by our
by the team which um
by our team
which develop these platforms so
for these you will get citation
information and general information on
how these analysis is done but you will
not get a reference until it is getting
until this entity is published so we
will
end the pipeline here and then if when
you click ok
you will get access to all the output
files and you can download these files
and perform your own visualization since
this is a visualization based
demo pipeline and then or you can as i
mentioned these are huge files look at
this these are huge files these are 8 gb
and 4gb files so since these are uh but
this is source code to
genomic visualization mind you so
we can perform visualization using the
tool that
and leveraging the use of the jbrowse
tool
from the platform itself
so
so you can fire up the j browser tools
analysis and then you can
do the visualization here
of the
map alignment file that you have
in the
in the demo pipeline i'm not going to go
in detail over how to go through this or
how to um get through this visualization
navigate through this visualization
because that will take another some more
time so i'm giving you a heads up on how
to access this demo pipeline which will
be helpful for you to understand the
pipeline building process and then
appreciate the output files that we are
providing you for
so
let's take a couple of more questions
and then quickly move on to uh
move on to the next session
uh yes
uh yes uh yusuf or omar vumi yusuf
if i'm actually
pronouncing it correctly
um
no diago the algorithms marked with the
t turbo by info are proprietary and
until it is published uh they are not
given for uh for implementation in your
own cluster computers and for the
services and tutorials we have we have
several
courses and lessons and programs that
will help you understand the logic
behind
building these pipelines and logic
behind uh using these softwares and when
you are interested in expanding your
understanding to command mode or the um
or the basic
basic environment in which these
algorithms are implemented and then for
space for some of the uh implemented
algorithms we provide you with our
script or we provide you with a script
along with the output files that you can
download and then put it in your
implement in your uh our environment or
other environment where you can analyze
or where you can perform your own
analysis so that that is also possible
so let me uh again
yeah let us um
move forward to the next session we are
already running a little bit late can
you see my screen please confirm it
before we are going to uh talk
thank you very much we before we are
going to talk about uh
some of the emerging variants and the
nature of those variants and why why uh
they are causing concern on why they
have caused concern in in the past and
um and and some of the driving forces
behind these
behind these variants and behind the uh
strains and different variants of
concern as it had has spread all around
the world
in the past couple of years so um
so yeah let's uh yeah and we will also
talk about how
in general the genomic data
how the omics data that we have been
talking for so for the last couple of
hours will help us identify and then
monitor the spread and monitor the
effects of these variants
in the context of
in the context of the viruses ability to
spread and cause
infection so
before we get into
characterization or characteristics of
different variants of concern in the
past in the for the past couple of years
in the pandemic let's
start by analyzing one specific mutation
uh that appeared in in around 2019 or
early 2020
so this this particular position
like um
614 g 614 genotype
glycine 614 genotype
was not detected until the until early
2020 like february
2020 and
and during march it is observed at a
very low frequency
and increase rapidly by april and may uh
by may it has
covered approximately like 70 percentage
of the sars cope 2 or kobit 19 variants
being populated by this specific
variant or that is characterized at
characterized by
ah
by calling it as g 614 genotype so um
so uh this this uh this change in the
transmission advantage of this change in
the strain prevalence from
pre
pre-february 2020 or from the reference
strain to g 614 strain
actually indicates the transmission
advantage of the viruses
transmission advantage of this specific
virus that it has acquired by the due to
the
did this specific mutation at the 614
position of the spike glyco protein so
uh
so uh this this is also related or
scientists uh performing these uh uh the
variation uh the analysis in this
specific variance also noted and
correlated uh this variant with the
increased viral loads in the covid19
patients that they have
sequence and that they have studied so
although this change is actually
associated with mutation in several
other viral proteins including the
including nsp3 or our drp
proteins but the role of the spike
protein in these observations were
were not very clear or remaining and
unidentified or undefined so
let's
let's see how um
this specific mutation at 614 position
that changes the aspartate amino acid d
to a glycine amino acid so hence it is
characterized as
d
614 g mutation at the spike protein so
hence it is s
g 614 so uh it's a
mutation at the spike protein so that
signifies s and the mutation results in
the
altered uh
variant with the glycine in the spike
protein so hence g and the position at
which this mutation uh up here though
640.
so um
so uh
so when when when people try to or when
researchers try to uh understand how uh
this could impact the transmission or
replication so when they they started to
assess
the role or assess this mutations role
in viral entry so
several experiments with both the viral
strains with the
normal or with the wild type and also
with the mutant type showed that the
g 614 infected cells um
exhibited approximately like 10 fold or
9 fold higher efficiency in viral entry
than
than the wild type which is
characterized by aspartate 6
d614 so
an interesting question here will be
why these viruses or why the viruses
that that carry um
this specific mutation at position
g
g 614 which which appears to be more
stable um
results in a more transmissible
transmissible
virus without changing any uh without
resulting in any changes in the
dc severity as observed by the um
as observed by the
by the scientists so uh it is actually
possible that um
it is actually possible that the um
functions of this spike protein of sg
614 changes or it actually
increases uh
uh um
with respect to the transmission and
with respect to the host to host uh
transmission uh with acquire uh with the
presence or acquiring acquiring of this
new mutation but there are also other
factors that will actually change or
limit the rate and efficiency of this
intra house replication so
the loss of the virus species that is um
for example associated with uh d 640 may
be compensated or maybe um
maybe
may be taken care of compensated by the
higher fusion efficiency of this
this specific uh
this mutant and it is also possible that
we our ability to detect sequence
changes at this early stage is simply
greater
um than our uh i mean uh
at this these stages then uh is is
actually greater than when we have
observed in the earlier stages so for
example uh
when the pandemic was just
establishing itself we might not have
several different sequences and hence
our ability to detect the sequence
changes at that stage was not uh
was not very highly
robust than comparing to a g 614 but
apart from that we might also have
appeared or we might also have um been
observing the presence or the emergence
of novel strain of these
of these viruses with the mutation at
614 position that changes the
amino acid from d to g so at this stage
we we still have a lot of questions uh
like this maybe because of the technical
error or maybe because of
because of natural uh
variations that is observed in this
observed in the viral
viruses evolution so um
we are not quite clear
where we were not quite clear at this
stage like in march or february where
this new variant is actually taking us
so
so
but one thing was clear at that stage
that there is a strong phenotypic
difference between the wild type d 614
and
and the new mutant g 614 and that
actually necessitated more study
to
to understand the impact of this
mutation and um and the course of the
disease uh
that we have that we had at that
particular stage so
at that point we actually identified a
few important um uh results that uh um
the sars cove to have acquired a
mutation in spike protein uh that that
actually uh made it more transmissible
and also um
without any um
significant increase in the virulence or
without any significance increase the um
increase in the change of uh change in
the diff this is severity so um
so uh
so at that point this remained us a
variant of variant of interest and then
as we already know
that um over subsequent uh months then
we actually understood
that there is a clear yeah this this
this actually tells there's a clear link
between the virulence of um the growth
rate of um the viruses are these two
specific position as i was talking about
how um how the phenotypical
characteristics of these two
different viruses are observed and over
the next
few months what we actually observed was
the variant that contained
this specific mutation has become has
become the predominant
mode or predominant
infection infected infection dominant
strain that infected the world that
infected there all over the world
around or since mid to 2020 so this
mutation likely increased uh the
affinity of the virus to bind to the
human protein inceptor or it actually uh
space or it actually increased
or it actually resulted in
higher transmission rates or
ineffectivity um in our ability to deal
with the original or ability to deal
with the wild type infection so far and
and this variance can also uh
this this variation this variance might
also have evolved due to the natural uh
selection as as we started to develop
some some level of
immunity to um
to the d uh 614 or wild type mutation
and and the selection pressure has uh
warranted these
this
this virals to develop a
new mutation that is more uh effective
in in transmission and hence uh
will actually result in hence actually
resulted in a large number of
people being infected with this variant
now which is known as the delta variant
at this
this position so um
however as we already actually
identified after a few
years after approximately eight or nine
months
the delta
variant also gave rise to another
variant like omikron and the delta
variant also was not observed anymore
and is no longer in circulation and as
the world started
to
understand the effect of
effect of the emergence of several new
strains uh from this horoscope to
variance and the uh continued uh and the
necessity to continue
our fight against this pandemic
situation so since then the collection
of genomic data continued and lot of the
analysis was
focused on determining
no no delta did not give birth to
monikon yeah i know yeah
but
the selection pressure gave birth to
delta and omicron
sorry thank you for uh correcting me so
uh yeah
since then we have a lot of genomic data
that has been continued to be
deposited and a lot of analysis was
focused on
determining
specific clades uh in the viral
phylogeny and and
and by tracking how these variants
change or how these uh different strains
change so um
so bioinformatics methods for under
understanding individual mutations uh
are through multiple sequence alignment
and that can be um combined with
pyrogenetic reconstructions too
and to track changes in the
evolutionary models and then we can link
them to the process of
linkedin to the
process of
how
a viral virus will continue to change
with the novel distinct strains and
planes separating from common origin
over the course of the pandemic so and
by the end of 2020 we had almo almost uh
um we have approximately 12 or 11
distinct trades and and the number had
continued to grow as we can um as we can
see
here um we have several new clades that
that begins to emerge and
and sometimes these these emergence of
new clades are likely to be likely to be
likely to be affected by the biases in
the sampling between various countries
as you can see
different countries have different
sampling rates and that might also
affect the
rate at which these clades are
represented uh in the um in the
phylogeny phytogenetic reconstruction
yes there is a specific difference
between clades and lineage so
clades are groups of
sequences that are
that are evolutionary that are
related or that are very closely related
in terms of their sequence and they
might or might not be
might not result in a different lineage
of interest right
for example when you have a specific
clade that is closely related and that
that is characterized because
to
characterize these specific uh
sequences that is represented in a clade
into a lineage that does not
stop or that does not
include only phylogenetic key analysis
that includes more uh
methods which confirms the presence of
mutation across these different
sequences and their effects in
the virulence and their effects in
transmission rates and etcetera etcetera
so um
lineages are identified through the
characterization of clades
so that is how the processes emerge so
lineages are character
characterization of specific source
coverage to lineages are the results of
analysis through photogenetic
reconstruction which actually results in
understanding or which actually results
in grouping of several sequences into
clades
of interest or codes of emotions so that
is how the processes actually
emerge or evolve so um
so as i
as we oh wait what happened yes so as we
were discussing so um
these clades are actually
based on multiple mutations that are
occurring at the same time so these are
not individual mutations so defining
mutations can be
non-synonymous or synonymous so uh this
can be found in for example
in spike protein but also found in other
genes there are other proteins that are
necessary for them
for their viruses to virus to evolve on
viruses to
[Music]
transmit and and
yeah multiply
so um
uh so uh it's uh it depends on our
ability to characterize these different
um
mutations that are present in um not
only in spite protein but are in
different proteins but
identifying mutations and defining and
characterizing mutations at the spike
level is of special interest to us
because then because then
we can
devise intervention methods like
vaccines and other methods which will
nullify or which will help us
deal with the
deal with the
infection rates of these viruses so um
so uh uh
that i mean due to the
yeah due to the distribution or when
when we analyze the presence of
distribution of these
mutations uh on variance of concern we
actually uh our scientists actually uh
understood or spotted that there is a
non-randomness to these specific
variants of concern so um
this this highlighted the significance
of uh for example tracking these
variants due by genome um sequencing
methods because i mean this
non-randomness can also be
the result of a special specific
evolutionary or selection pressures that
we have actually put on these uh viruses
has
we have uh yeah we have put on these
viruses by our means to combat these
viruses
infection mechanisms and
virulence effects so um
so overall these these clades are
actually represented as i mentioned
by mutations that affect different
proteins
and
different functional domains of the
proteins but
not
all mutations will be beneficial to
viruses right some might result in less
efficient
replication or less efficient
transmission or less
efficient immune response so
when we actually understand or when we
actually perform
um
a very thorough genomic data analysis
which is which is currently how we dealt
with how we are dealing with this
pandemic we can actually
understand which
mutations are beneficial to the virus
and which mutations are not beneficial
to the viruses and thereby it will also
help us in
developing
in developing
efficient methods and efficient
vaccination vaccination
vaccines that will
encounter these pandemic situation so uh
so these
these non-randomness will also help us
understand the evolutionary pressures
as i mentioned as that
that ultimately
can be
characterized by observing low and high
frequency mutations
from the data for example if you take
the whole genome sequence of sars and
then
focus on one specific subunit of the
spike protein and then we can understand
the
frequency of mutation at different
position not all the position
are mutated at the same
frequency and um
when we are when we map that to the
structure we can get a sense of what are
the positions that are um
[Music]
specifically or that are more prone to
being mutated and what are this position
that the
virus wants to keep it relatively
constant to
not change too much of its virulence and
not to not change too much of this
pathogenicity so these these analysis
can be can be extremely helpful for us
in um in combating or in uh and
designing the viruses uh for
this pilot
currently as we have mentioned um there
are different variants of concern that
are characterized first they were first
characterized based on their country of
origins and called unnamed based on
their country of origins and now we have
moved past that and we are now
calling that based on
accepted nomenclature like
alpha beta delta gamma and the micron
and
and there are
characteristics mutations that define
these lineages and different strains
within these lineages also and these
mutations as we have been talking um
can result in small changes in the
structure of the spike protein or
changes in the proteins that forms the
envelope of these subscribe to virus and
and
these changes at these specific
positions are of um major concern to us
because uh of our ability to um
our ability to design a vaccine based on
the identification of these based on the
position of these proteins and when
these viruses finds way to evade our
immunological
response then we have to develop some
more
vaccination uh
some more variants of the vaccine that
we have and that is why a continued
analysis and continued uh
understanding of the
of the
development of different lineages and
different strains of these
sars co2 viruses is of utmost importance
so um
so this this is actually possible uh
this is actually
necessary
because many of the insights and can
come
due to or come from the researchers come
from scientists who are re-analyzing the
data that is deposited in the public
domain and this is one of the this is
one a preprint which actually appeared
recently and talked about um
deletion specific deletions in spike
protein so uh
this this this
specific uh
paper or preprint actually
deals with recurrent deletion regions in
the spike protein and by by quantifying
the nucleotide positions or by
quantifying the
mutation frequencies at specific
nucleotide positions so they identified
four specific or four uh distinct
clusters for recurrent deletion regions
in in
in the
in the spike pro uh protein um in the
spike protein of the saskov2 and these
and
and the percentage of these delicious
evens actually um
[Music]
actually uh help us
will help us understand the significance
of these uh of these deletions and and
if we can leverage or if we can
make use of this information by creating
uh
um
by uh uh
creating a vaccine or a variant of this
uh variant of spike protein that is uh
that is um that can necessitate that can
uh
um that can generate the immunological
response in our uh in our body
based on these
clusters then that is that will be that
that is uh
yeah worthwhile to
explore and under this
this data or this uh this specific uh
the specific data and their analysis can
be uh can be performed by by selecting
theirs
selecting all the sequences that they
have selected all we can do the same set
of um analysis for the new um
a new strains that have emerged since
the uh published since this data has
been published and
we already have a
spheres consortium or uh open genomics
consortium for for the sars kovi to uh
response that continues to
[Music]
monitor and continues to continue to uh
analyze the
important changes in the virus that is
that are circulating and and gain
specific important insights uh to a
trace uh
trace the spread of these
these viruses and new spread of the new
emergence of new strain
and uh we can also get a lot of data
about the transmission dynamics and the
host responses and evolution of these
viruses from this consortium and um
and and very many uh
[Music]
re-analysis efforts on the publicly
available data is actually help us
understand uh the impact of these uh of
the variance
and their
association association with the
phenotypical characteristics of the
viruses so
while it is
therefore important uh to continuously
analyze the uh genomic sequence data and
and with high quality precision and with
high quality sequence data that is
present and that has been published all
uh published in the public repository
a consensus or continued analysis of
this
genomic sequence data will help us
be prepared for
what is going to be or what is what this
pandemic has for us in
nature so
there are different ways to acquire
these samples since clinical samples
since collecting clinical samples might
not be
viable or might not be possible for um
for everybody so um
[Music]
many sequencing efforts are actually uh
related or actually um
[Music]
interest
are actually developed uh
using interesting alternatives such as
waste water detection of sars kobit ii
and and
and a project an exemplar project in
this specific
paper using this specific paper which
actually
collects the waste water from
from the new york state uh
department and then identifies the
presence of a predominant source co2
lineage that has infected people
in new york during that particular
pandemic so hence they have
characterized not only the
strains that have
that are currently
that have been circulating during the
sample collection uh sample collection
time point but also identified important
other variants of um uh variants of
these sars coveted virus that are that
are clinically not absorbed so these
kind of um analysis actually helps us
the possibility of detecting sas cov2
and presence of subscribe to viruses and
different strains
by not collecting patient data but
through alternative methods of
identifying our understanding or
characteristics of copy to linear so um
you can go through this project which
will help us
also understand
the significance of different
variants and that are reported in this
by by collecting the waste water
by collecting the wastewater samples and
then analyzing multiple different
strains that are under found in the um
founder of the wastewater uh sample
collection of new york state so um
so that will conclude our session today
in the discussion of uh several variants
of concern a couple of important
important
[Music]
repositories that i want to talk about
before going to uh yeah
next two sessions in the upcoming days
which will uh
which we'll discuss or which in which we
will discuss
in detail about bioinformatics analysis
like uh evolutionary studies and
phylogenetic uh recrea i mean
um
uh photogenetic
uh tree building and origin tracing and
variant calling reporting and then we
will also technically get a hands-on
demo on how to create
a report on genomic sequencing data
using custom r scripts and using the
processes um from uh talbot bioinfo
platforms analysis so
let me quickly
okay
okay let me quickly go through if we
have any more new questions
okay let uh let me share my screen
so here we can uh can you see my screen
i think you can see the screen
the ncbi virus database is one of the
yeah thank you ncbi virus database is
one of the one of the excellent
repositories where you can understand a
lot about
different sequences related to multiple
different strains or different
submissions of source co2 and they have
yeah they have a
specific section for sars
if i can find them
i think you can search by its name
yeah
yes so
okay so uh yeah so we have
a lot of data regarding source code too
so you can look for those uh specific
data
and ncbi virus is one very important uh
platform and you can also go for
pangolin website
so that is going to cover that is going
to
help us understand different lineages
in a very uh useful uh um
um
visualization efforts like uh if you
want to understand the lineages
we can go through different uh
characteristic characteristic lineage
lineages and then uh
search for those lineages and then how
they are uh how they differ at the other
common
countries
so these can also go to
let's go for
can you please yes we can actually go
for different variants of concern and
which is called by their code names and
this is omicron and you can go and look
for
the characterizing s ps that define
these omicron data and different
cumulative sequence counts uh over time
and they're spread and etc etc this can
also give us
ways to characterize the sequence that
we have sequenced so far or we can use
custom bulls scripts to understand the
presence of
these
various variants in our
in our data and then characterize
our
sample data so far so um
when you yeah
do we have any more queries related to
today's sessions
these two are some of the most important
i mean you can get the whole genome
sequencing or the whole genome sequences
in faster format from the ncbi viruses
resources and
you can also get a lot of other uh
information like uh
different strains and different uh
samples collected as a segregated or
samples collected by different
geological location or different
sample
deposition date and these
and identifying the emergence of
different variants
that we can
group by um by their uh um
place or their time of uh up appearance
will be uh will also be a very
interesting uh
uh
finding for us to
get through this so if you have any
queries let me take those queries and
yeah
if not then i can hand over the session
back to spurs
okay so there are no more questions
thank you so much dr
for such a wonderful session
i know it was
sorry for the background ways yes i know
it was an extensive workshop and we'll
be meeting now day after tomorrow
with another uh
three hours of extensive workshop we'll
try to
include some breaks that will be really
helpful for you all
and for today's workshop i'll also be
sharing the recording of each and every
session so we had three sessions today
uh in the workshop i showed you the
recording go through it once again and
if you have any questions then please
let us know and we'll be able to resolve
them for you put them in the slack
channel i'll share the link with all of
you why i'm uh email so i'll share the
recording with all the workshop uh
participants the attendees and i'll put
the link to the slack channel join the
slack channel and
put your questions up there in the
channel and we'll be there to help you
if you are not able to join the slack
channel
you can mail us at support at the rate
pine dot bio or marketing at the
and
we'll be able to assist you
okay now for those uh who were
interested to be a part of this workshop
we had uh invited all of them the first
day of the workshop uh was
a free session
but to be to become a part of the other
two workshop days it's important that
you have the access to the licenses of
the tea bioinfo server and also of the
omixlogic learn portal so to
get the access to these resources it's
important that you register yourself for
these workshops and get the access to to
the resources that you can go through
learn from and get a good hands-on
practice with so now i'm going to
explain you the registration process of
how you can become a part of the other
two days of the workshop and also with
the two days of the workshop you will
get the access to the resources that is
going to be for a month
so i would like like to clarify uh this
point here that the resources that
you're getting the access to is for a
month but these sessions are just for
three days that is what we mean by the
three days extensive workshop access
okay now coming to the
uh
[Music]
registration part
so to get yourself registered for the
workshop
you need to visit the program page i've
put the link to the program page in the
chat box when you will scroll down the
program page
you will find three levels the first is
the beginner level the second is the
intermediate level and the third is the
advanced one these all three levels
differ in the type of subscription or
license we can save for the uh server
and also the workshop so i'll just
quickly explain this to you in the
beginner level you will get the access
to all the resources the recordings the
uh divine info server and the uh
resources on the portal as well
and also the group sessions that we are
having right now in the uh intermediate
level you will get one-on-one mentor
support and uh the mentor will be able
to assist you and also may have the
symposium that is scheduled for uh 31st
of march and first april so you are
going to get the access to the symposium
as well now when i say the access it uh
means the um
the access to become a part or the the
chance to become a part of the two day
extensive symposium that we are going to
have and in the symposium we will be
having
speakers from all around the world from
reputed institutions and universities
will be talking about different areas of
research and also we'll be having
various competitions um
one of which is the
presentation competition and we have
the
poster presentation competition for
which we're accepting abstracts right
now and if you're interested to become a
part of the poster presentation
competition specifically in the
symposium then i'll also share with you
the details over a meal let's do this
i'll share the details uh with the
recording for the symposium as well in
the mail if you're interested just
please submit your abstract so that
the mentors can go through it and let
you know if your abstract has been
selected for the poster presentation
competition or not and if it does get
accepted then we let you know what the
format of the poster has to be how you
have to present and all the details that
you you would require to learn more
about it
okay so that was about the intermediate
level in which i told you that you will
get the uh acids from international
symposium for the two days uh symposium
and you will not need to pay the
additional amount for the same and in
the advanced level
you'll uh also get some extra time to
propose a research question right and uh
also you you
will be getting
the um access to the mentor guidance and
also the one-on-one sessions where
you'll be able to take uh your questions
from the mentors directly
so that was about the three different
levels bigner intermediate and advanced
and i think few of the points are
missing from the advanced level i add
them and
you can then go through it
so if there are any other questions then
please let us know so that we can uh
answer them
and if not right now then maybe you can
email us and we'll be there to assist
you further
now talking about tomorrow's session
so uh we discussed a lot today we
discussed about genomic surveillance and
sequencing data analysis and the trends
behind the emergence of sas cove two
variants
so all the things that we went through
today it's important for you to go
through the recording revise the
concepts and also get a good hands-on
practice on the server and absorb
whatever we went through today and
practice it yourself that's why
tomorrow's session is asynchronous
tomorrow i am just going to share with
you the resources some of the lessons
and the coursework that you are supposed
to go through from the massage portal
yourself at your own pace tomorrow and
then you you can take your questions day
after tomorrow from the mentor day after
tomorrow we'll have the live sessions
and the details of the live sessions
have been mentioned here the first
session will be on genomic surveillance
data collection sequencing and biomatics
analysis and the second one will be on
downstream analysis of genomic data
evolutionary studies phylogeny origin
tracing and reporting
and the third session will be on
creating a report on genomic sequencing
data using cloud processing and custom
art scripts so these are the session
session details for the session
that will be conducted on my become a
part of for the other two days of the
workshop and also get the access to all
the resources and the
symposium
then please go through the registration
page and get yourself enrolled before
the uh limits of the seats is over and
for any
query any questions uh the mail ids are
there
in the chat box
you you can mail us and we'll be there
to assist you
omar me is saying does the three levels
have the same courses yes the courses
are same the course content is same the
resources that you're going to get is
the same it is just the type of facility
that is different uh in the advanced
level you will get
one one-on-one
session with the mentor where you you
can take your questions also propose a
research question that you would like to
work on discuss with the mentor and
propose one research question that you
would like to work on
and in the intermediate one match first
and also um
sorry march 30
1st and 1st april and just give me a
second i'll pull out the symposium for
the page and also the details about the
simple symposium so that it's easier for
all of you to go through these details
and have the knowledge of these upcoming
workshops
so this is the link to all the workshops
and also the symposium
towards
the end of this particular page you will
be able to learn more about the
symposium or maybe you can just simply
click here and learn more about this
symposium that you'll get the access to
and uh here is the schedule of all the
workshops so as i told you in the
beginning of this session that we're
going to have
six uh like five workshops and the sixth
is a symposium so we have five workshops
the fifth one is a specific workshop for
faculty and mentors only
so you can find all their details of all
these workshops appear on the page
and
i've just scrolled it uh
very quickly but i'll share the link
with all of you definitely via an email
and i just got reminded of a point here
that it's very important for you to
please add
the email addresses support address
bio and marketing attitude omixlogic.com
to your contact list address book so
that you get the mails in your inbox
directly and they don't land in the spam
or the promotional boxes
any other questions
okay so there are no more questions then
it's time uh
to say goodbye and we will be meeting
day after tomorrow for our uh third day
of the workshop and for tomorrow i'll be
sending out the important resources for
second session thank you everyone for
joining have a great day
you